mesdames et messieurs bonjour ici bruno
savard direct du parc des plaines
d'abraham à québec pour la suite de
notre couverture spéciale de la visite
du pape françois au canada et
particulièrement ces jours ci à québec
nous sommes sur ce site parce que c'est
ici que les fidèles avaient été conviés
pour regarder en direct ce que vous
ferez fort probablement avec nous tout à
l'heure regarder en direct la messe qui
sera célébrée à sainte anne de beaupré
par le pape francs soit
constat il y à quelques dizaines de
personnes présentement sur le site des
plaines d'abraham c'est un peu comme
hier on est là pour vous rendre compte
de ce qui se passe et de ce qu'on voit
et c'est le premier constamment il ya
quelques dizaines de personnes que je
vois arriver ici à ma gauche mais
nécessairement il n'y a pas foule encore
bien sûr l'activité principale
aujourd'hui c'est la messe qui est à
sainte anne de beaupré ce qu'on entendra
encore le pas françois demandé à des
excuses quels seront les lectures qui
seront retenus les lectures bibliques
seront retenus pour cette messe bien
particulière on le verra avec nos
invités aujourd'hui j'ai deux routiers
notamment qui sera avec notes
historiques la dernière fois qu'une
messe a été célébrée par un papa sainte
anne de beaupré c'était le 10 septembre
1984 avec le pape jean paul 2 un pape
qui était à ce moment là en pleine forme
on est dans une situation totalement
différente aujourd'hui la route 138 je
veux vous le mentionnez même si on n'est
pas dans le grandiose de 1984 la route
138 qui passe juste à côté de la
basilique sainte anne de beaupré est
fermé en ce moment à toute circulation
les gens qui avaient à s'y rendre devait
prendre soin de navettes fluviales soit
encore redit navette routière qui avait
été fournie qui avait été mis à la
disposition par le comité organisateur
donc aujourd'hui au programme la
diffusion en intégrale de cette messe à
sainte anne de beaupré qu'on va vivre
ensemble et puis des invités qui se
relaieront soit ici à notre tribune ou
encore indirecte de sainte anne de
beaupré pour faire part de leurs
impressions et de leurs récents ainsi
déjà qu'ils sont là prise allemand qui
voudront entendre probablement des
excuses encore du pas françois et pour
nous aider dans ce choix pour remettre
en perspective encore une fois les
crédits qui est avec moi pour jour à
l'unc pour nous beaucoup de monde non je
sais mais j'ai posé la même question il
ya c'est qu'elle allait de la semaine
des coupes rases comprend des systèmes
assez frappant loi et moi
il ya les plaintes sont tranquilles des
fois de matin cache pas son vélo ici le
y ait plus de monde c'est non à l'armée
mais il faut dire quelque chose pour
rendre justice à quelque chose ici parce
que je pense 184 quand jean paul ii est
arrivé au québec il y avait
effectivement des gens qui disaient
qu'est ce qu'il vient faire ici et tout
ça il y avait la résistance
chez les nouveaux laïque de la société
québécoise peut-être y avait on est en
mouvement des décroissances peut-être
mais jean paul ii était comme vous
disiez justement un homme en pleine
forme dans la soixantaine c'était un
miraculé il avait échappé à une
tentative d'assassinât
il tenait tête à l'union soviétique
c'est un personnage mythique et la foi
n'était pas la même chose qu'aujourd'hui
nord exact et là il y avait de
l'événementiel et c'était c'était
c'était quelque chose de joyeux si vous
me passez l'expression ici on est en
train de participer une tragédie le
dénouement d'une tragédie comment ça se
fait ce qu'on est ce qu'on présente des
excuses quand est ce qu'elle est et
pardon est ce qu'on peut parler de
réconciliation on parle de 13 une
tragédie qui dure depuis longtemps on
n'est pas du tout dans la même
atmosphère en partant il ya des gens
d'église qui nous ont dit on sera
bientôt faire le parti
pis bain toutes ces choses-là mises
ensemble est-ce que ça fait que la perte
de la formule 1 sur la pandémie oui et
que dit une dame qui m'a écrit ce matin
pour me dire mais pas parce que ça me
tente pas mais la pandémie mornas j'ai
tout à fait que je vous regarde à la
télé tous sont bien ensemble je pense
que ça met des bémols et je pense que le
truc dont il faut soutenir ces
je ne crois pas qu'on se souviendra de
cet événement aussi seulement en
fonction du nombre de personnes y ont
participé
n'est ce pas ce qu'on s'en souviendra ça
passe à l'histoire se sent plus
davantage sur ce que le pape aurait dit
une poésie comment les les premiers les
premiers peuples du canada auront réagi
à ça je pense que c'est ça qui est
capital et n'oublions pop vous nous
l'avez répétés puis c'est encore
important de le faire
n'oublions pas que ce pape est venu ici
principalement l'invitation des
premières nations qui ont vécu des
traumatismes et qui ont demandé au pape
d'accord on entendu vous excuses avant
mon avril maintenant ce n'est sur nos
terres le dire et ça juste ça c'est pas
rien fonds à prendre conscience je sais
qu'on se répète là dessus mais il faut
vraiment prendre conscience il restait
chose je remarquais toutes les personnes
qui sont passées à nos micros à du
cadeau doit on parler de hockey alors
maintenant au delà des paroles ce qui
peut y avoir des gestes est ce qu'on
peut passer à l'action qu'est ce que ça
veut dire passer à l'action et on entend
souvent une chose qui revient c'est
toute la question des archives à la
queue qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on trouve
dans les archives de la communauté des
oblats temps celle d'aider des soeurs de
l'assomption qu'est ce qu'on trouve dans
les archives des diocèses qu'est-ce
qu'on trouverait là dedans qui
permettrait peut-être au moins aux
programmations de identifie ce qui s'est
passé avec leurs propres enfants essayer
de décortiquer ce drame là pour enfin
régler la ferme pour aider la faune
certaines primes chinois na waie à
l'arrière on me disait que le t on
disait qu est ce que le secrétaire
d'état du pape vient bien faire avec lui
ici semble-t-il qu'il y en a discuté
entre autres avec le ministre
responsable monsieur la première dit des
affaires autochtones est ce que on a
passé le message clairement
ao secrétaire d'état nous on aimerait ça
que vous fassiez pression sur les
communautés et sur les dix semaines pour
que ces questions là avance qu'on avance
sur ce terrain-là excuse et c'est
concret à ce que ça serait comme ça dans
une homélie à soit dit en passant j'ai
aidé la femme et des autres des archers
pas comme ça que ça va
aller aujourd'hui le principal de
l'activité est à sainte anne de beaupré
j'ai des collègues qui sont déployés en
ce moment ma pierre merci et colin côté
pologne à vii à sainte-anne-de-beaupré
alexandre lait est ici sur les plaines
elle pour rendre compte de l'ambiance
commençons par ce qui se passe à sainte
anne de beaupré à la basilique bond
marqué remercie je goûte vous demander
de nous décrire nous quand on a commencé
notre émission notre déclic il y avait
beaucoup de monde ici on décrivait
l'ambiance comment ça se passe à
quelques mètres de base et les caisses
qu'une fiabilité en ce moment
oh oui bruno yens fébrile si les défilés
bond est présentement et les fébrilités
va s'intensifier parce que le pape doit
arriver ici sur le sanctuaire de
sainte-anne-de-beaupré dans quelques
minutes à 9h20 ils vont circuler sur le
site avec sap ap mobile
entre temps ce qu'on attendait ce sont
les excuses du pape qui l'a prononcée
depuis son arrivée au canada autant à
edmonton qui erre ici à québec la messe
va commencer à 10 ans s'avère
l'intérieur et 4000 places soixante dix
pour cent d'entre elles sont réservées
aux autochtones ainsi à l'extérieur se
classait la france connaît mais y en
avait pas nécessairement de réserver
pour les autochtones on en a vu beaucoup
mais c'est difficile de déterminer
leur pourcentage aussi y avait 1000
places disponibles au début domaine
vital pour notre est un endroit où on
compte de nombreuses attaques tonnes
depuis quelques jours justement pour
pouvoir visionner cette messe sur des
écrans géants
la sécurité ici sur l'aide des pneus et
l'état cru il ya des policiers partout
juste pour vous donner un exemple
les journalistes ont eu très peu de
liberté de mouvement on est enfermés
dans leur bulle m de sécurité à la
veille d'aller parler à des jeunes on
est capable de parler à ce jeune
chanteuse sur le quad et des clôtures on
a réussi à parler à quelqu'un entre une
maison avec journaux parlent et se sont
faute des noms doc tonnes sont ici et
c'était important pour eux de l'être
même si le discours du pape la messe
sera célébrée particulièrement pour les
autochtones important pour eux d'être
ici parce que ça à la réconciliation
c'est une affaire de dons de variétés
quelques personnes par conseiller
s'intéresse pas seulement pour canada
c'est là pour tout les peuples
autochtones le peuple on va pas les
laisser faire tout c'est cette démarche
un dossier déjà c'est trop lourd donc
c'est nous tous qui pourtant cela est
dans ce processus de réconciliation
c'est une démarche de foi aussi pour
montrer que biya que la paix qui est
vainqueur j'aimerais qu'ils aillent plus
loin dans ses rangs son pardon de
reconnaître les torts de l'église en
tant qu'institution et non pas seulement
de certains chrétiens certaine au
regroupement dans le pays
n'est ce pas un hasard si on se retrouve
à sainte anne de beaupré j'aimerais bien
qu'on rappelle l'importance de 52 dans
j'écoute sur dans la croyance pour les
peuples autochtones
mais vous savez saint-andre c'est la
grand mère de jésus donc la mère de
marie et vous savez à quel point les
aînés ont une importance particulière
pour leur temps là dans les yeux dans
les communautés autochtones alors pris
pas pour rien que ça ce par souci depuis
de nombreuses générations et des peuples
autochtones qui viennent si à la
dernière semaine de juillet pour
célébrer la fête de ses dents alors
c'est pour ça qu'on fait ça ici
aujourd'hui quelques informations sur la
mer le lâcher double du pape qui va
porter aujourd'hui y est a été conçu par
un autochtone de la région un autochtone
locale un actif huron wendat surveillera
aussi les trois soeurs volantes de
pessamit ce qu'ils vont faire un champ
en innu lors de la messe les autres
champs seront surtout des chants
autochtones et évidemment
ali le but de cette mais cela pour le
pape c'est de faire en sorte que les
gens puissent se réconcilier entre eux
et avec l'église catholique évidemment
alors ça commence bientôt 7 à 10 heures
on n'attende pas pour monsieur ça pour
vous il table
merci méridien on se retrouve un peu
plus tard koné côté poil à des pommiers
lointain vous êtes vous à l'entrée de la
basilique dans une autre section là on
comprend bien que le parvis divisé en
plusieurs sections et êtes dans le
secteur où on aurait réservé l'endroit
pour des dignitaires déjà qu'ils sont et
veiller particulièrement à la
célébration
je suis avant l'entrée de la basilique
et pas seulement les dignitaires depuis
ce matin vous savez ya les aînés les
survivants qui peuvent rentrer à
l'intérieur d'un beaucoup qui sont en
marche et de coux en chaise roulante
c'est par ici qu'on les fait rentrer
également mais je vous montre un peu à
400 me l'entrée des dignitaires là vous
le voyez il ya beaucoup de dispositifs
de sécurité saas et des agents de la
sûreté du québec je me permets de vous
interrompre un petit instant parce que
je sais que nous montrions l'entrée mais
je voulais vous dire que prendra ce cas
nous les images qu'on voit c'est
l'arrivée du pape françois donc qui
s'amène à 52 compris avec avec la fia
donc on va on va continuer sur ces
images là et je vous laisse aller dans
le disque dur que vous aviez entreprises
connectées
je vous disais tout simplement que merci
de me le dit bruno mais je vous ai
simplement que beaucoup dispositif de
sécurité et on voit l'entrée pour
comprendre c'est que ce matin deux
commères bien vous disais l'oeil et de
l'ambiance et la fébrilité mais
l'ambiance n'est pas à la fête il faut
dire que dans les gens qui sont rentrés
eu six mois j'ai parlé à plusieurs chefs
autochtones qui représente quand même
une élimination après c'est des opinions
individuelles mais pour comprendre qui
en a certains qui seraient pas venus
normalement qui seraient restés à la
maison mais qui viennent en soutien à
d'autres survivants des pensionnats qui
viennent vraiment pour les aider pour le
soutenir il ya vraiment des intervenant
psychosocial sont présents il ya
vraiment des gens avec la médecine
traditionnelle on est là dedans il ya
plusieurs chefs qui me disent écoutez
moi j'aurais aimé ça qu'on aime plus
église on revient à salé demande avec
les les excuses on veut que tu es là
dessus deux chefs autochtones
ya beaucoup beaucoup de confiance si je
parle avec tout le monde tout le monde
de toutes les nations et puis c'est
unanime
on a de l'espoir et c'est sûr que ça
prenait
on entendait l'optimisme un peu dans
l'extrait de l'entrevue avec l'ancien
chef konrad sioui vous entendez un peu
le pessimisme dans l'eau donc voyez on
est un peu dans ces deux ces deux
paradigmes là un peu ici je vous dirais
mais il ya quand même beaucoup de gens
qui sont présents moi je le remarque
qu'il ya beaucoup d'attaquants si le
moment autochtone et pour la petite
histoire c'est vraiment un moment où on
veut garder ce pour les aînés et je
parle avec justin prune picard un peu
plus tôt qu'il disait que lui il était
supposé avoir un siège dans la basilique
mais finalement il a laissé il a cédé
son siège à une survivante d'un
pensionnat parce qu'il m'a dit moi ce
que je veux c'est vraiment que le pape
quand on parle ici je suis une fois de
l'aspect politique le des chefs que je
veux qu'ils se souviennent vraiment des
survivants le regard des gens qui ont
vécu dans le pensionnat et on va
commencer comme ça donc on peut écouter
monsieur picard justement c'est québec
qui est vraiment le le le focus là pour
voir si ça va aller plus loin donc on
est un peu fébrile par rapport à son on
espère beaucoup pour moi ce qui est
important c'est que le pape françois
retourne haram je pense qu'ils se
souviennent de moi leur jeu que c'est
bien des personnes qui l'ont rencontré
que sont les survivants des cheveux
gaufrés
selon
l'ema pour les sections vélo doit
prendre recueil et laisser la place aux
aînés c'est leur moment
[Musique]
merci beaucoup collet on aura l'occasion
de revenir avoue un peu plus tard ici
sur le site des plaines d'abraham je
regarde les gens commençaient à arriver
allons voir avec alexander hleb on gc
depuis tôt ce matin
certainement se poser de sérieuses
questions il y avait même une scène de
personnes et puis le monde qu'on peut
parler quelques centaines total
500 personnes environ derrière moi
qu'ils sont arrivés en paix tout d'un
coup parce que ce matin on est arrivé
très tôt aux alentours de 7 heures et il
y avait un couple que je connais bien
maintenant
les jeunes et serge qui attendait qu'ils
avaient essayé d'aborder bien à basic de
sainte anne de beaupré ça n'a pas
fonctionné donc se sont dirigés vers les
plaines d'abraham
c'est impressionnant de voir tout ce
site lot to l'organisateur
l'organisation autour des thèmes
d'abraham et bord seulement deux
personnes on se posait de sérieuses
questions comme vous avez mentionné mais
finalement bon ça se remplit lentement
mais sûrement et les gens arrivent
principalement par autobus donc un coût
de 50 cents personnes qui arrivent d'un
coup et bien présentement on s'affaire à
tribus et des bouteilles d'eau parce
qu'il fait déjà extrêmement chaud on
s'assure que les gens sont bien beaucoup
sont arrivés avec leur propre chaise de
camping
c'est un axe est vraiment c'est tout le
contraire de saintes à dire que c'est
pratiquement pas du tout sécurisé le ya
quelques policiers s'amuser police de la
ville de québec mais ces accès à tous et
donc les gens peuvent arriver et
repartir quand ils le souhaitent je vais
parler d'entrée de jeu de ces jeunes et
serge je vais vous laisser les entendre
sur leurs motivations à venir ici de
côté les peines à ma
sortie je continue à voir de nouveau ce
matin en un lieu certainement beaucoup
et je pense que cela permet pas de
billet
y aller jacques en l'enserrant supports
ont néanmoins et c'est de pouvoir sous
la pression
de ses pairs quand même
pratique est beaucoup plus calmes et
côté des vainqueurs ce sera la première
fois que je viens ici pour le voir si je
m'ennuie à québec j'espère glover plus
de monde que sont là parce que se fait
la leur
j'espère qu'on va voir plus de monde que
ça c'est de valeur et le jeu reprend
c'est beau il reste que on avait prévu
pas mal plus de monde que ce qu'il y
avait même un site de débordement de
alexane merci alexander hleb les images
que vous voyez là d'où j'arrive en
direct de sainte anne de beaupré encore
une fois un bain de foule pour le pape
françois on va aller je suppose on est
en mesure d'avoir le son parce qu'hier
le son nous nous donnait beaucoup de
l'ambiance allons-y on va le vivre un
peu ensemble à vent de face à notre
prochaine à éviter ici les adrets des
plaines d'abraham
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on essayait avec michel au dunk
les premières nations à l'être à sainte
anne de beaupré si cette rencontre
l'homme dans ce pays ful alain crevier
ya vraiment 7 pions djia recule pas
françois et ml il rencontre dans ce
pont-là particulièrement le lieu de
rencontre avec liseré les délits les
représentants des premières nations sont
pourtant essentielle non c'est
vrai parce que on voit bien qu'il ya une
raison ce voyage ce n'était pas de
serrer la main à tous tout le gratin
politique du cannois ce n'est pas son
objectif mais n'ont pas acheté il ya là
un objectif
c'est un objectif de tragédie on est à
l'intérieur d'une tragédie chantage est
quelque chose qui a changé dans le
discours que j'ai entendu ça fait comme
thème quinzaine d'années quelque chose
comme ça que je parle de ces histoires
de passionnant et avant j'ai remarqué
que tout le monde focus s et vous
permettez à la sauce et cibler la
question des agressions des agressions
sexuelles dans les passionnés était
difficile de faire comprendre il y avait
ça c'est sûr mais ça c'est un
conséquence de quelque chose qui était
peut-être plus grave qui est une
décision politique sur le conflit et
aussi la responsabilité de l'incision
catholique et je l'en à part métal je
pense que tout le monde y compris
massage tout le monde sait de grand
talent on sait pourquoi ces excuses
semble déplaire à certains tu sais c'est
un changement dans la perception de la
connaissance du dossier qui peut-être
plus important que ne l'imaginent je
pense et ça nous permet d'apprécier le
fait d'apprécier dans le sens comprendre
qu'avec moins de monde pendant qu'on
aurait imaginé ce avait été
la grande fête et que peut-être une plus
grande signification du voyage que le
nombre de pèlerins de gens qui seront là
est ce que cette tournée en pack mobile
on doit l'avoir différente de celle qui
l'a fait au stade du commonwealth et de
celle qu'il a fait ici pas besoin de
l'autre c'est tellement différent de ce
qu'on voit ou à la saint pierre quand il
promet places 1k le ccd lire un peu près
mais il sait l'huile pas fou il sait
très bien qu'il y ait parmi les
touristes et des gens qui sont croyants
il est voit d'ailleurs les religieux les
religieuses il y voit ces gens là ils
ont une scène quelque part qui les
distingue mais il connaît aussi la sorte
son impact touristique là c'est autre
chose mais là c'est la vuelta
ajoutez à ça le drame la trashitude un
passionnant ici oui les la boutonne
s'était pas nécessairement gelé d'hier
c'est pas nécessairement prévu d'être
des paris
7 cette histoire de tourner en pack
mobile c'est arrivé au programme il y à
quoi deux semaines peut-être parce que
ce n'était pas nécessairement au
programme au départ belles vues
aériennes ce que vous voyez le sait le
parvis
de sainte anne de beaupré bon ça nous
permet vraiment de comprendre la
géographie ouest chroniquer type de
tournai fait le pape france voilà ta je
sais pas s'il ira de l'autre côté parce
que jugée au graphiquement plus au sud
de l'autre côté il ya une place où il ya
des gens qui sont capello depuis
plusieurs jours maintenant
plusieurs milliers de personnes qui sont
sur place je sais pas si dans sa tournée
avec la papamobile je crois qu il doit
s'y rendre également se séparer chaussée
l'autre jouera en alberta ya tenté de
faire une percée dans les parkings de
stationnement adverse à ce buzz non il y
avait beaucoup de gens sur le banc dit
lucho ça plus vieri c'est en plus
chaotiques et parce qu'on lui a
peut-être innove c'est peut-être une
bonne idée à une autre époque quand il
était jeune et petit 26 sportif le juge
a reconnu comme ça mais plus agile et
moins - dans la douleur il répété étonna
qu'il exige de faire un geste comme
celui là les vins ils épient c'est le
genre de chose qui l'apprécient et le
fait bien ceci dit il faut comprendre
quelque chose qui était qu on oublie
parce qu'on le voit fait photos de
pâques mobile et jean la pelouse ici ce
qui donne des bisous à des enfants tout
cela et ça me donne un peu l'impression
que c'est bono qui est en ville pourtant
sa charge entre origine de trahir mon
âge ça donne l'impression que c'est
barbecue ta ville
c'est pas une rock star c'est le plu le
plus c'est la remettre à temps se
souvenir que c'est le chef d'une g
traditions spirituelles
je voyais déjà tout prêts nous qui
courent est littéralement au voir et
revoir passer le pas de mobile il y
avait une bande de potes
c'est pour moi une cinquantaine de
personnes qui en avait d'autres qui
derrière courait pour aller au devin
pour le revoir et revoir les revoir
passé c'était fascinant voir ce
revêtement est finie fallait yade qui
ont un outil éditions puisque c'est pour
ça qu'on était ici mais c'est fascinant
oui je me suis demandé si le dalaï lama
aurait cet effet le tout je sais qui y
est c'est regarder on en voit encore la
sas et déjà qu'ils étaient d'un côté et
qui repartent de l'eau pour le roi de
l'autre côté alors
quand vous disiez c'est pas bon non non
non
on va on va rester sur ces images
l'homme mais peut-être qu'on prend on va
venir une peluche sur le plateau parce
que je veux profiter de ce moment là
pour vous présenter notre prochaine
invitée pendant que bon je sais ça reste
la tournée de pâques mobile et on pourra
continuer de la vivre ensemble
visuellement mais mon prochain invité à
ma gauche il s'appelle sébastien richard
et les porte parole des victimes de
prêtres pédophiles monsieur richard
bonjour
quand on est hissé le moment autochtone
qui on l'a tous compris que c'est le
moment tant pis que ces excuses là ils
sont pour les services et le génocide
culturel d'engis dans les pensionnats
autochtones mais souvent j'ai entendu
pions choix vos messages qu ainsi les
gens qui disent ou aimer l'église a fait
d'autres victimes vous en faites partie
le porte parole donc des victimes de
prêtres pédophiles
de vous avoir avec nous aujourd'hui je
veux qu'on mette les choses bien au
clair ça n'enlève pas le moment
autochtone vous voulez pas nuire à
ce moment autochtone savez monsieur ne
change pas d'histoire alors j'ai besoin
de vous dire que je comprends très bien
à quel point les sévices subis par les
nations autochtones c'est un enjeu de
société qui est absolument fondamental
sur lequel on peut pas passer à côté
alors alors une fois qu'on a dit ça que
le pape soit venu pour ça je n'ai aucune
objection à avoir et je n'ai
certainement pas juger de cette
attention une fois qu'on a dit ça le
pape se retrouve en ce moment à sainte
anne de beaupré
chez les rédemptoristes la seule
congrégations religieuses qui a fait
l'objet d'un jugement sans appel contre
lui lors de recours collectif alors la
question que je me pose c'est que compte
tenu des propos j'ai envie tir lancinant
du tape sur les nerfs sur la notion d'
excuses qu'il veut apporter
est-ce qui va aborder ce thème l'eau ce
matin je le sais pas mais qu'il aborde
pop une chose est certaine c'est que je
pense que j'ai la comparaison avec n'a
vu que justin bieber loup avec bono
selon la génération qu'on peut avoir se
pose se pose tout à fait parce qu'
est-ce qu'on est dans un exercice de
relations publiques un exercice pour
tenter de redonner à l'église catholique
en europe qu'elle ne plus au québec je
pense que question se pose il ya quand
même eu eu un pape à la demande des
premières nations qui est venu ici
piatti l'église pour un genou par terre
demandent pardon bon demander pardon à
dieu présenté ses excuses solennelles a
parlé de honte envers les peuples
autochtones est-ce que là dedans
pour vous quel jeu si vous parlez au nom
de plusieurs vixen ya un peu un peu de
réconfort des deux héros qui il peut le
faire pour eux pour as et de la faire
pour nous c'est monsieur bouchard et
pour sa jeunesse chez moi
monsieur savaria pas il n'y a pas une
seule victime d'agressions sexuelles que
choisie et agression sexuelle on va
s'entendre là-dessus et généralement les
gens qui nous agressent dans le camp de
coder des représentants de l'église ce
sont des gens qui
avaient pour fonction de nous éduquer de
nous apprendre à devenir des adultes
bref de nous former ils nous ont brisé
un certain moment donné et ce qui est
très regrettable dans toute cette
histoire c'est que en tout cas ça fait
quand même un certain nombre d'années
que je que je porte ce dossier là est ce
que je constate c'est que les excuses
qui sont venus de la part de l'église
jusqu'à maintenant pour moi ne fait
aucun doute qu'elle devint un seul
intérêt un intérêt financier stadi
d'alléger les montants qui devront payer
aux victimes ça pour moi c'est
absolument pas de doute alors dans ces
circonstances le lorsque j'entends les
propos du pape à l'évidence il ya des
avocats qui sont allé lui dire saint
père ne nous incriminer pas parce que
des avocats qui attendent seulement sur
pour prendre pour pouvoir présenter vos
déclarations devant les tribunaux alors
je je pète un peu la page web
d'autant que dans un instant on devra
aller à collet qui
pourra probablement discuter un peu avec
justin trudeau qui l'y a instamment à
passer plusieurs messages aux pattes
françois richard vous venez parler de
l'aspect financier
dans le code des peuples
demande de recours collectif dans le
corps des victimes de prêtres pédophiles
il ya des recours collectifs y ait eu
des ententes encore vous vous en avez un
avis bout en bout de piste on parle
d'argent d'autres choix je le retiens la
question la question puis on va entendre
justin trudeau
fait plusieurs années qu'on regarde
comment justement on peut s'assurer
d'une croissance économique qui
fonctionne pour tout le monde c'est plus
vrai qu on peut juste les cdd des
avantages aurais je pu espérer que la
l'économie va croître ça prend une
économie inclusive et c'est pour ça que
que ce soit la location canadienne aux
enfants que ce soit de créer des
nouvelles de nouvelles places en
garderie que ce soit les investissements
pour nos aînés on a augmenté elle le
supplie le supplément de revenu garanti
à on est là pour aider les gens parce
que ça crée des classes trompe au dos
qui n'ont pas d'électricité seulement on
est dans un pays industrialisé
est ce que c'est normal non mais c'est
pour ça que depuis depuis sept ans on y
travaille quand on est arrivé au pouvoir
il y avait cent neuf communautés
autochtones qui n'avaient pas accès à
l'eau potable on en a éliminé 120 avis
d'ébullition d'eau mais il ya encore du
travail à faire on continue à faire la
réconciliation continuer à investir mais
évidemment c'est pas juste le
gouvernement fédéral c'est les autres
paliers de gouvernement et c'est les
institutions et c'est pour ça que
l'église soit ici pour à faire des
excuses pour s'engager à continuer le
travail et de la réconciliation c'est
une journée très importante pour le pays
qui devait aller plus loin je pense que
il va sûrement répéter les excuses qu'il
a à faire mais aussi parlé du travail
que nous avons tous à faire pour
reconnaître l'humanité et défendre la
culture l'identité de thau s'étonne
surtout par tuer les communautés
autochtones ces jours ci
c'est pas moins de regretter mais j'ai
entendu directement de plusieurs leaders
et membres des communautés autochtones
qui aurait espéré qu'il y aille un peu
plus loin mais qui ont quand même reçu
un
certain niveau de soulagement avec ses
paroles c'est une étape vers la guérison
mais évidemment il y avait à faire vous
l'avez dit la meinau mais oui moi ça
fait longtemps que le gouvernement ait à
faire des excuses et investi des
milliards de dollars pour essayer de de
corriger les erreurs qu'on a faits du
passé parce que on reconnaît que pendant
que les lire les pensionnats autochtones
est en train d'enseigner aux jeunes
autochtones qui n'avait pas de valeur
qu'il n'avait pas d'identité qui
n'avaient pas de langue toutes les
écoles partout au québec partout au
canada était en train d'enseigner la
même chose à des enfants non autochtone
donc ce legs de manque de respect de
d'enlever la dignité profonde à des
autochtones ça fait longtemps que s'est
incrusté dans notre société ça mène à
énormément de défis de difficultés dans
les communautés autochtones sont pas de
leur faute et donc nous devons en tant
que gouvernement et tous les paliers de
gouvernement est là pour corriger ses
erreurs du passé qui ont encore une
présence actuelle dans notre véhicule
tous les jours aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup de travail à faire
le premier ministre justin trudeau qui
encore une fois va pas plus loin que que
le pape
oui mais on savait parce que regarder la
progression le cheminement 2008 stephen
harper prononce des excuses mais on a
souvent dit comme réservations que
c'était du bout des lèvres quand est
arrivée la fameuse la dernière activité
de la commission vérité-réconciliation
café travail colossal si ma mémoire est
bonne il n'était pas sur place harris
trudeau c'est une autre attitude on va
un peu plus loin des milliards qui a des
médias qui ont commencé à être dépassé à
en toutes sortes pour toutes sortes de
raisons sous harper ça s'est poursuivi
sur tous nos là il vient dire quelque
chose que je trouve intéressante parce
que ça relève du systémique et je sais
qu'au québec des fois well done here
lies tiempo sentence il ya eu des débats
politiques des skis dit dans le fond me
suis trop douce qui est intéressant
c'est pendant que les églises est en
train de dire aux autochtones dans les
pensionnats que vous ne valez rien votre
culture de bourrier vos lampes sont
interdites pendant qu'on faisait ça mais
d'un système d'éducation arrière au
canada ou non autochtone on enseignait
la même chose à propos des autochtones
leur culture vaut rien c'est des
méchants ac dc c'est bob connaissez tous
le discours autrement dit si l'ensemble
d'une société qui était en train de je
pense que c'est intéressant de mettre en
parallèle parce que ça signifie aussi
toute la responsabilité non seulement de
l'église mais aussi évidemment du
gouvernement canadien et des canadiens
alors reste maintenant la portion église
qui se fait lentement petit mot petite
allusion au lierre on ne dit plus de
milliers de voir comment va réaliser les
aînés ils les appellent à l'action de la
commission vérité c'est un petit pas à
la fois et ça devient ardue si ça
devient peut-être pour certains exact
est décourageant pour sébastien richard
qui avec nous je vous le rappel porte
parole des victimes de prêtres
pédophiles
je veux continuer la conversation parce
qu'on était rendu par des d'argent parce
qu'en bout de piste carton et en asie
demande de recours collectif il ya
toujours un chiffre qui vient avec soin
dans votre cas
été victimes de prêtres à sainte croix
il ya eu une entente hors cour vous en
avez eu vous avez eu un monde est ce que
ça change quelque chose elle est
platement question les payes tu mets ça
change quelque chose de recevoir un
chacun moment danic peu importe le
montant une question qui est très
importante je vous remercie de la poésie
dans le système de justice jeu
différente la première chose que je
pouvais faire c'est j'aurais pu faire
justice moi-même ils ont qu'on constate
que comme comme société on a dit que ce
n'est pas une bonne chose bien alors je
lui ai pas fait ensuite on peut aller au
criminel ce qui est une possibilité
aussi je les fais mais là contenu quand
on se fait agresser sexuellement il y
aura vraiment un public qui assistera
donc c'est ma parole contre celle de mon
agresseur y a choisi de mentir du début
à la fin donc plus bénéficier du doute
raisonnable et la dernière chose c'était
une action civile parce que leurs
courses un recours collectif est faite
en vertu du code civil et ça signifie
que la paire prépondérance de la preuve
lequel est le plus convaincant alors
j'ai témoigné mon agresseur est provenu
donc de gagner que alors donc maintenant
sur l'aspect financier
qu'est ce qui leur fait le plus mal en
ce moment qu'est ce qui fera sortir une
gourde réagi dans le recours collectif
le deuxième qu'on fait compter cinq
points ce moment-là moyenne 7 10 ans que
ses trains et les moyennes des victimes
est âgée de 85 ans
donc si on fait un calcul cynique la
pluie en a qui meurent moins ça va
coûter cher alors d'effroi c'est froid
mais c'est bête mais comment ça se fait
que ça traîne depuis dix ans cette
histoire là c'est pas nous qui avons
acquis sa malice quand cour suprême leur
on a fait était forcée dialyse pour
obtenir l'autorisation d'enclencher un
deuxième recours collectif donc ce qui
arrive c'est dans ce contexte là ce que
je constate c'est que la seule façon qui
permet aux qui oblige l'église à bouger
c'est lorsque ça lui fait mal à poèmes
dans la zone un aspect financier et
lorsqu'on voit la façon avec laquelle le
peuple s'exprime en ce moment je le
répète c'est tellement évident que des
avocats qui ont dit saint paul il ne pas
nous incriminerait pour succès repose
sur un texte parce que normalement il
sort de son texte à en crever oui mais
voilà il s'entraîne de façon très
étonnante
excepté sur le moment c'est parce que je
sais pas dans l'avion il ya dipturus
elle s'avère y était peut-être dans
l'avion de retour après cambridge on
sait jamais on va continuer de suivre ça
en terminant
quel est votre niveau d'espoir qu'il
parle de vous aujourd'hui qu'avant pour
vous personnellement nous aurons vix a
jugé au qg aucune attente a cédé girl
non je pense que ces sujets le discours
est besoin à ce moment le plus de la
somme mais ce que je retiens préventive
en terminant c'est que on a tous
souhaité - personnage les faits j'ai
fait cette démarche là de dire que je
voulais des excuses de la part de mon
agresseur et ne sont jamais venus au
contraire il a menti sous serment devant
le tribunal alors c'est important pour
les gens qui souhaitent avoir un
qui souhaitent obtenir une réparation là
dedans c'est pas de l'espérer de l'autre
ces deux l'exigé pour soi et dans ce
contexte là j'en viens à la conclusion
que la seule façon c'est de prendre des
moyens juridiques qui s'imposent pour
obtenir ce dédommagement de parce
qu'autrement ils ne viendront pas
thierry charles merci beaucoup de votre
prix top avec plaisir merci ça nous aide
à comprendre bien des choses on me dit
qu'on a vu passer jean chrétien tout à
l'heure il fait partie des dignitaires
présents à la basilique sainte anne de
beaupré qui s'appelle la mersey qui sera
présenté dans une trentaine de minutes
voici un monsieur chrétien ses premiers
ministres du canada qui font pas et fait
partie des très très très intéressant de
l'ordre parce que j'ai déjà entendu
monsieur chrétien à l'époque où il était
ministre responsable des affaires
autochtones 1969
il veut même pas on ne passe pas devant
les caméras c'est dommage parce qu'il
l'a entendu dire de force des choses à
propos du passionnel alors arrêtez
intéressante intéressant non
petit mois jérémy l'entente de voir est
ce qu'il est il est présent là y
reconnaît qu'un drame quand même le sait
il a été premier ministre et ministre
responsable des affaires autochtones
alors tsar est intéressant c'est un
personnage qui
a côtoyé cette question la part à 60 à
50 ans des dizaines de personnes des
milliers de personnes probablement
sainte anne de beaupré qui sont là pour
vivre ce moba quelques centaines qui
sont ici sur les plaines d'abraham pour
le vivre également se joint à la
conversation maintenant
celui que connaissaient bien alain
beauchamp sociologues et des religions
qui s'ajoute à notre panel d'analystes
vieux bouchard bonjour bonjour d'abord
et ses tables la même façon que j'ai
merci alain ce matin première réflexion
sur ce que vous voyez ici car on dit que
c'est le moment des peuples autochtones
on le comprend aussi personnes
exactement il beaucoup il ya beaucoup de
non non non non non exactement et c'est
alors c'est un bon jeu contre ce qu'on
se disait hier juste un peu le reflet
aussi de la situation du shaykh du jeu
ici au québec et comment toute cette
question là aussi le mobilise peu les
gens sentent eux comment se fait il que
malgré tout ce matin et on le voit en
direct de sainte anne de beaupré il y a
des centaines voire des milliers
d'autochtones qui sont là et qui veulent
oui entendre le pape qui viennent leur
présentant ses excuses mais ils veulent
voir le pape ils veulent toucher le papy
veulent respirer le même air intel pas
comment ce fait je pense que pour une
bonne part d'entre eux ce sont encore
des croyants il faut pas oublier que
il ya une centaine d'années ce serait
quand même bien saint quentin la
majorité des amérindiens s'y était
catholique pratiquant et tout ça a
chaviré début des années 1980 au moment
où justement on a commencé à parler des
pensionnats et des scandales et cetera
il l'a des entrepôts des gambier
documenté c'est justement ça cool il ya
eu un vrai coup homme qui s'est mis en
place
et parallèlement ça il sait il ya eu les
amérindiens se sont rassemblées on crée
surtout une nouvelle culture qu'on
appelle le parisianisme ou entre autres
on va même s'échanger des rituels on a
vu hier à la fumigation donc le sport du
canton
c'est a pratiqué par les indiens des
plaines et puis là il ya d'autres cette
nuit qui ont adopté ces rituels là
hélas est mis en place parce que je
parlais hier c'est une rencontre où là
il ya eu des tentatives d'intégrer des
rituels amérindiens dans les rituels
catholique et qui fait qu'en bout de
ligne on avait il reste encore et des
amérindiens qui sont catholiques
pratiquants croyant tout au moins et
pour qui la figure du pape représente
quelque chose c'est fort une bonne
partie des fonctions de mai en même
temps alain j'ai l'impression qu'il
ya des gens sur ma qui viennent pas dans
leurs pratiques parfois d'une foi qui
vaut de l'or l'institution ça je pense
que c'est toujours un peu étonnant dans
la dans le canton tient compte du
contexte tragique mais je pense aussi
j'entendais des gens dans l'ouest qui
disait que non seulement ils veulent
voir le pape ils veulent que le pacte
des voix ils veulent que le pape
retourne à rome avec eux dans sa tête en
les voyant ce ne sont pas les victimes
je peux parler pour l'épauler paul et
pour les peuples et des premiers pape au
canada muc c'est pas un concept ici on
peut envoyer ce message là ici le pape
peut voir et rencontrer serrer des mains
prendre quelqu'un dans ses bras qui a
été une victime on veut que ça
s'incruste dans la mémoire de ce papy
éventuellement que se transmettent au
suivant je pense qu'il ya ça aussi qui
peut être important à être vu piètre
forcément entendu la suspension étant
entendu être vu que quelque chose
s'incruste l'homme être vu ou et mais
aussi participer c'est à dire que il
faut voir dans la rencontre
d'aujourd'hui devient une expérience qui
votre vie
et tout à l'heure vous mentionniez on
l'a vu au moment où la top model s'est
promené dans la ville de québec les gens
voulaient être là est toujours
surprenant dans le contexte actuel
convoitent des mères
deux élus et un garde du corps qui va
aller le porter
donc au pape il ya là quelque chose de
l'expérience tieto au delà effectivement
de l'institution et il ya quelque chose
qui ait vécu et c'est d'ailleurs ça
c'était un des traits caractéristiques
du fait religieux actuel où les gens
veulent avant tout chose vivre quelque
chose et que quelques tout ça donc leur
rapportent qu'ils puissent grandir aux
tourments et transformé par cette
rencontre là est tout seul avec une
grande distance face à l'institution
comme on mentionnait hier alors c'est un
peu ce qu'on voit actuellement
douchez pas surprenant de voir qui est
des milliers de personnes même de
traditions amérindiennes soit là pour
vivre quelque chose dans 20 minutes
c'est la messe tantôt j'ai ramené à la
mémoire déjà que la dernière fois qu'un
pape a présenté de messe à la basilique
sainte anne de beaupré c'était en
septembre 1984 jean paul ii on retient
quelque chose de ce passage qu'est ce
qu'on retiendra de la présence du pape
françois à sainte anne de beaupré
aujourd'hui en 2022
au revoir le ya beaucoup d'attentes
ça va pas au cerveau qui vont être
prononcée est ce que il tel ou tel mot
va surgir et cetera mais aujourd'hui
c'est donc c'est une rencontre entre
l'église catholique par son représentant
donc le pape et
les amérindiens et avec leurs
représentants ou si politique mais aussi
et surtout les ics survivants ou tout au
moins des membres de ces communautés
alors je pense que ce qu'on va tenir ses
sept rencontres et là on va voir comment
elle voit se dérouler
comment la liturgie va se dérouler et
moi bah bien sûr j'ai un regard
particulier je regarde la sociologie à
la sociologie
bahia un espace social où les acteurs se
rencontrent et il
décède dans cette rencontre là bas on
essaie de faire sa place au soleil et
pour faire sa place au soleil on a
besoin d'instruments au nom de besoin
d'atouts avec nous alors ça c'est ce que
bourdieu appelait à la capitale et est
ce qu'on va voir aujourd'hui c'est
commun
ce rituel lac et la messe devient un
lieu où tange du comté de l'église
catholique que du côté des amérindiens
on va on va utiliser des atouts pour se
positionner les uns par rapport aux
autres alors moi je vais regarder la
messe tout à l'heure comme étant non pas
un match où les deux équipes qui se
rencontrent mais il ya cette dynamique
là quand même où on a des individus qui
se positionnent et c'est là où arrivent
l'importance des mots qui sont utilisés
est-ce qu'on va utiliser des par exemple
des symboles amérindiens mais si on
utilisait c'est pas la mer un chien
c'est en quelles perspectives il sait
tout ce qui faisait dire aujourd'hui en
danse rituelle da
alors qu'est ce qu'on va retenir bien
sûr c'est beaucoup plus la rencontre le
songe place d'un point de vue général
mais du point de vue des relations entre
l'église catholique et les peuples des
premières nations c'est vraiment comment
tout ça va se dérouler qui ce qui telle
chose qui fait telle chose et ça c'est
ce qui a marqué seulement c'est
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui me retient un
peu les relations entre les amérindiens
et l'église catholique au moment où on a
voulu intégrer des éléments
amérindiens dans les cérémonies
c'était de savoir mais on le fait pour
quoi pour qui et quel sens ça prend
alors c'est tout seul rookie aux deux
voulu soulager dans quelques heures et
sainte anne de beaupré alain puis je
suis j'avais un peu d'information là
dessus et tu imprégné de la présence
autochtone où on ne parlait de la
wii mais on a parlé juste avant de
parler du fait que dès les peuples
autochtones avaient
cet immense respect pour sainte anne la
mère de jésus mais ça va au delà de ça à
sainté ne vous prie c'est vrai c'est
vrai mais je pense que c'est un
personnage là on a beaucoup entendu par
exemple 50 grand mère on a tous un grand
respect du bon ensuite je suis pas
toujours très convaincu de scola dans
notre société d'aujourd'hui mais parfois
bien ensuite on a parlé de du fait que
c'était une année mais le père françois
est un aîné c'est quelqu'un de fragile
aujourd'hui on le voit et il voudrait
bien il parle souvent d'ailleurs des
années c'est depuis quelques semaines
c'est curieux quand on comprend on
comprend cette dynamique là mais il
reste que je pense que quelque chose de
profondément catholique tic par exemple
par là je vous disais tantôt que dans la
basilique de sainte anne de beaupré il
ya trois reliques de sainte anne j'ai vu
réagir vous êtes vous de quoi parle de
notre côté non non non kateri kateri de
son sanctuaire sainte anne 3 un bout de
doigt un but d'avant bras et
je réagis comme ça il y en a partout des
reliques qui réussit à des choses comme
ça dans l'église catholique c'est ça
fait partie d'une démarche je sais pas
comment la qualifier peut-être que
monsieur josé mieux que moi comment
l'exprimer mais moi je considère dès
fois que c'est comme à l'extrême et je
sais pas ce que ces choses-là sont
encore pertinentes je ne sais pas le
sanctionner comme sainte anne c'est pour
cette entreprise c'est comme un
sanctuaire c'est quelque chose d'unique
c'est comme l'oratoire saint-joseph
comme zelaya pose du stv quelqu'un de
saint-andré qu'il sait c'est beaucoup
alors il faut y adhérer je me tourne
vers la sociologue
saviez douce je m'excuse de vous avoir
trouvé je le sais que c'est ainsi puis
les gens le savent probablement mais on
drague on a besoin de se faire expliquer
ça pourquoi il ya seront vénèrent des
reliques lors des daytona et
émotionnelle une des dimensions
importantes phénomène rude juste
l'expérience et l'expérience pour un
être humain ça passe par ses cinq sens
donc de conceptualiser pour des
théologiens pour des philosophes ça va
bien mais pour la majorité des gens ça
passe par nos cinq sens et dans tout le
toucher est ce que font les reliques
c'est justement c'est ce lien entre une
personne qu'on a jugé comme état
exceptionnel qu'on va + 1 5005 et le
peuple élit gens et là on va pouvoir
toucher et le résultat c'est la personne
doit se sentir transformer mais comme
cette colle à cet art de bons prix ça
peut même aller jusqu'à les guérisons et
ça c'est sûrement un des aspects aussi
qu'il qui peut plaire aux amérindiens et
à cet aspect là de guérison de relations
particulières on peut avoir qu'une
personne
alors si sauf simple macabre mais à un
moment donné
le sens premier qui se sont des
ossements c'est le tiers du frère andré
est complètement dépassé par autre chose
par là que les chercheurs dans sainte
anne de beaupré bon c'est la tradition
pour annoncer jeu qu'il ya quelque chose
de particulier je suis quelqu'un autour
de la table à la réponse à cette
question est ce que c'est particulier
lorsqu'elles présence d'un pape
l'utilisation d'armes à quoi sert baur
je me tourne à ma droite je me tourne à
ma gauche ben c'est le tue les trois
réponses à toutes les questions ce cas
là il m'a peut-être monsieur russie sera
avec une photo me restait une liturgie
de la réconciliation je sais pas j'ai
hâte ouais moi aussi fier de voir où
nous en savons exactement puis qu'est-ce
que ça si je veux continuer sur ce
concept alors les rallyes qu'est-ce
qu'on est dans le même dans la même
dynamique que on va se recueillir par
exemple se maintient une présence
physique une pierre tombale c'est à peu
près on dit c'est l'adjectif mapaq pas
sans suite deux secondes à ce qu'est ce
que c'est que le cncr s'égayaient dans
le corps qu'il a qui est décomposé qui
est en train de se décomposer et sur
l'édition avait quelque chose qui te se
décomposent pas mais surtout où on va
inscrire le nom de la personne est
quelque chose qui va les représenter
on est des modes depuis quelques années
par exemple des photos ou avec des
choses qui auront plus à la personne est
très souvent quito - dans la famille
immédiate on va voir le sentiment
d'apporter par exemple du flair ou
quelque chose qu'on va déposer alors
encore une fois il ya cette notion de
toucher est commun aux principes de
voyons c'est une pierre ça ne peut pas
être la personne sinon la pierre devient
la personne et c'est là où ça devient on
est au delà de chance promis et donc
voilà comment on pourrait interpréter et
sa boucle la boucle et ça nous aide à
comprendre aussi de la douleur des
parents de cet enfant dans les
pensionnaires ont été enterrées sans
identification il n'y a pas de lieu pour
dire mon enfant mais peut-être aussi que
ça explique que je suis content
d'entendre ça parce que je me dis pour
moi ce thème la neuvaine est un mystère
à sainte anne de beaupré la
participation des des premiers notes du
premier peuple à la vie catholique et
encore pour moi un mystère et vous
l'avait bien dit parce que c'est une
fois ou l'autre l'institution est là
peut-être qu'il ya là un lieu d'une
expérience parviennent à certains
quartiers nos modules au mois de juillet
se rencontrer à être ensemble et puis
peut-être que c'est la seule fois de
l'année comme michel ce vol pour l'essai
devient comme une expérience quittera
sans beaucoup de succès et l'or à
s'intéresser à ce que vous venez de
mentionner vient rejoindre le sociologue
à moi parce que on retire que ceci est
logique pas par là la spécificité ou la
caractéristique d'une religion c'est de
réunir des gens est effectivement que
tout à coup des gens des quatre coins du
québec et même des états unis un aviv et
s'installe sur le camping qui est juste
en face de la basilique et ce pendant
tout ce temps nous devons partager des
images
à l'intérieur de la basilique sainte
anne de beaupré on accueille les gens à
vannes le début de la célébration
officielle à qui sera dans une dizaine
de minutes
su chang vous demeurez pas très loin
parce que tantôt on aura l'occasion de
revenir à vous pour certaines
explications certaines observations que
vous aurez
bon voilà c'est ce qu'on fait c'est
qu'on annonce la queue dans une scène
deux minutes cette fois on aura
l'occasion de parler je l'espère bien
avant le début de la messe avec génocide
qui va on se posait des questions tout à
l'heure sur les choix de lecture qui
seront faites j'ai le goût de ce qui
sera avec nous dans un instant puis alet
bouchard qui reviendra avec ses
observations tout à l'heure donc je vous
le rappelle dans une scène de minutes on
va
débuter puisque on va faire pour la mère
ce ce qu'on va vous la laissez vivre au
plus possible l'idée de vous présenter
de telles célébrations et de vous
présenter ces événements il si vous
choisissez des regarder avec nous à la
télé mais c'est parce que vous ne pouvez
pas vous s'y déplacer alors aujourd'hui
on vous offre la possibilité de le vivre
avec nous avec les milliers de personnes
qui sont à sainte anne de beaupré donc
tout à l'heure on vous présente rope
pratiquement dans son intégrale la messe
mais on a besoin de guide pour nous
aider à d'abord comprendre les choix
liturgique qui seront faits et de
comprendre le message que ce qui sera
livrée par le pape françois il ya eu
plusieurs messe célébrée par le pape
depuis son arrivée et à chaque fois on
dirait qu'il ya une thématique alors
aujourd'hui j'ai hâte de voir ce qu
quelle sera la thématique est pour nous
aider à nous y retrouver lg rousset
professeur titulaire à la faculté
théologie et de sciences religieuses
université laval bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous parce que j'avais de la
lettre notre guide vous allez nous aider
à comprendre parce que ils vous
connaissent mieux que quiconque est la
liturgie j'ai l'impression puis le jeu
corrigez moi si je me trompe il ya eu
dix thématiques première mèche première
célébration on était dans le pardon par
la suite on est allé dans la
réconciliation au stade comme nous avons
été dans l'évangélisation plus pur et
puis par la suite la famille la gran
moun
aujourd'hui quel type de lecture quel
type de prière une autre
d'une part on a choisi parmi les prières
eucharistiques
l'église catholique en prière
eucharistique pour la réconciliation
retient alors c'est celle là qu'on a
choisi aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on est la
date est donc on entendra ce mot
régulièrement
il ya également comme dans toute
célébration ça s'ouvre la célébration
près de l'équipe d'ouverture par un
moment pénitentielle
alors il ne sera pas
j'allais dire pauvre pape il est
toujours
en 4k née d'un des cadres qui le fit un
peu et un moment donné on le voit
s'exprimer avec beaucoup plus de
spontanéité lorsqu'il rencontre des gens
et c'est comme si c'était là qu'il est
vivant mais rencontres protocolaires à
la cité à la citadelle les liturgies
également
fige les choses nous mettre nous mettre
dans des rôles
brême un peu la spontanéité et surtout
comme il est souffrant n'est pas malade
mais les quand même souffrant ouais et
il est usé gras est ce que est ce que
une célébration comme celle
d'aujourd'hui est particulière parce que
c'est le pape
dans une certaine mesure mais
ça donne une messe oui alain connu ça le
temps de jean paul ii il l'évoquait tout
à l'heure et il n'y avait pas simplement
sont pas deux mais il y avait un gîte
surgissent d'un cérémoniaire du pape
marini qui
[Musique]
était un homme créatif
et un homme qui avait des initiatives
alors que là maintenant avant mon élan
avec un cérémoniaire qui est beaucoup
plus stricte comme on la lit comme on
dirait oui alors
je pense qu'on
je ne veux pas avoir trop d'attentes
parce que plus les attentes sont hautes
plus les
déceptions sont conséquentes
je suis persuadé que vous serez
intéressé à ce qui s'en vient
des jeunes week des jeunes qui sont là
présents aujourd'hui alexandre drolet
est juste à côté de la basilique avec
notamment des gens qui ont choisi de
vivre vicky non désolé désolé loge je
corrige
écoutez nous
donc tout près de nous des gens qui se
sont déplacés ici qu'ils voulaient vivre
ce moment là et qu'ils sont bons si je
reviens c'est à cette information
l'accent des jeunes
oui c'est impressionnant je vais y aller
pour prendre un bain de foule finalement
je voudrais 1000 1500 personnes environ
sur les plaines d'abraham en ce moment
et beaucoup de jeunes et on en avait
parlé au cours des derniers jours avec
la météo en ce moment il fait tellement
chaud à québec que c'est bien que les
personnes qu'ils sentent qu'ils auraient
pu avoir un certain malaise luxe en
mobilité réduite ne sont pas
nécessairement déplacer du côté des
plaines d'abraham parce que c'est vrai
que ça peut donner rapidement dangereux
où vous les coups de chaleur ou de
quelconque malaise alors j'ai rencontré
des jeunes se sont déplacés notamment
les premières images qu'on peut leur
montrer ce matin quand il ya vraiment
leur vous l'avez vu avec moi bruno ces
centaines de personnes qui sont arrivées
d'un coup il est environ 300 me
confirmer cette information le ce sont
des jeunes en bottes 30 ans qui venaient
d'un peu partout au pays vancouver
toronto montréal québec se sont réunis
se sont organisé un voyage pour venir
ici regarder la messe en direct sur les
plaines d'abraham également
d'autres familles qui apportent leurs
jeunes et cédric notamment que je veux
faire entendre quelques instants il a 12
ans il a toujours voulu voir le pape de
très près ils étaient là hier pour le
tour de pape mobile sur les plaines
d'abraham suire déplacés pour voir la
messe qui va commencer dans quelques
minutes
alors je vous laisse les entends
et super king a il est
par contre très excitée parce que c'est
comme deux fois de venir au québec et
peut-être pu connaître plus de gens ici
et savoir la chasse avec les autochtones
et entendent
la lettre d' excuses du pape vraiment
les autochtones ils ont marché comme
deux jours pour venir pour voir le pape
juste pour voir le pape et ils sont
ainsi ils ont tout écouter
ce qu'ils ont à dire
avec sa droite qui sur les plaines
d'abraham on sera vous probablement
également après la baisse pour avoir les
réactions marie pierre mercier à la
basse et vega 5 minutes de la bascule et
l'ambiance que vous ressortez sur place
et justement bruno je suis avec une dame
de manawan le pas bien de passer alors
je lui ai demandé à la dame ce qui est
la fatigue tout ce qu'est ce que ça vous
fait de voir le pape je lis vue est
passé tout proche et puis
mon coeur s'est emballé parce que c'est
parce que tu spécial de voir un symptôme
et puis les patins
il est là aussi pour les autochtones
pour les premières nations alors c'est
important pour vous d'être ici pourquoi
c'est important
c'est important parce que
c'est moi qui a organisé le voyage pour
les survivants survivants des
pensionnats de chez moi des chéneaux et
puis aussi les aînés tout l'autobus
le 47 personnes hillion gérer ses avoirs
pour les autres des billets d'intérieur
pour tous le monde l'or alors ils sont
tout en bas et profite du moment je suis
fier parce qu'elle met sa routine toute
façon la lépi mais daignait souci est la
seule à l'extérieur oui je devais de
rester à l'extérieur parce que il me
restait des billets est utilisé à donner
à des personnes que je pensais que le
seuil besoin oui c'est une grande
générosité moi qu'est ce que vous
attendez n'est ce pas aujourd'hui il a
prononcé l'homélie qu'est ce que vous
attendez de lui
[Musique]
il a déjà fait beaucoup depuis son
arrivée n'a touché notre coeur
et puis
on amasse à l'égard d'un coq longtemps
oui oui mais
la première chose que je voudrais c'est
que ses paroles ses excuses
chemine dans le coeur de tous les
survivants un survivant du pansement
progrès le coeur pour guérir les
blessures
laissées j'ai parlé avec bien des gens
qui ne sont pas toutes comme qui sont
ici aujourd'hui qui disait justement
c'est important d'être là parce que la
réconciliation 6 pouces seulement la
sphère de l'église et des autochtones
sinofert de tous qu'est-ce que vous
passez des ajustements qui a des gens
qui soient le pour vous pour vous
appuyer sur ce merveilleux ça me
réveille aujourd'hui on est jeune nation
on est juste un peu merci beaucoup bonne
mais ça commence alors bruno la mère du
braqueur oui
merci
et juste pour nous situer où est ce
qu'on est et puis on vous laisse avec la
nes gilles routhier qu'est ce qui se
passe maintenant alors la procession
d'entrée est terminée
et la messe sera présidée par le pape et
le chant d'entrée ces peuples de baisser
et là dessus je pense que
depuis l'idée du front des ide ibode
l'église mais il erre soit ça me
tracassait cette affaire je suis allé
voir dans ces textes des dernières
années pour lui l'église c'est un peuple
de baptiser pro quand il parle quand tu
es chrétien qu'il parle exactement au
caire
la messe donc débute à l'instant nous
allons la vivre ensemble moi aussi
depuis le privé
la paix soit avec vous
fraîcheur
préparons nous à célébrer le mystère de
l'eucharistie en récompensant notamment
péché
j'ai fait
c'est pourquoi je suis
il
là
que dieu te ça
nous fasse une série cause
qui nous perdons nos péchés et nous
conduisent à la vie éternelle
il
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
et
prions le seigneur
dieu est miséricorde et réconciliation
coffe maintenant au centre des jo de
sanou peu qu'ils reconnaissent une toile
quelques heures ne paierait tous
vient à notre aide dans ta bonté
fait nous accueillir ça reste est apparu
le dp qaderi atteint volonté de
récapituler tous les choses dans les
clis tu
lui qui dit rien avec toi à noter qu'un
je suis un dieu pour les siècles des
siècles
dans le futur nous triturer appel c'est
évidemment j'aime domaines estimant que
nous allons
et tout
quand longue désolé à tous
où
es-tu dont il répondu j'ai entendu ta
voix dans le jardin j'ai pris pas parce
que je suis nu et je me suis caché le
seigneur repris qui donc tu as dit que
tu étais nu aurais tu manges et de l'art
dont je t'avais interdit de manger
l'homme répondit la femme que tu m'as
donné c'est elle qui m'a donné du fruit
de là et j'en ai mangé le seigneur dieu
dit à la femme que tu fais là la femme
répondent le certains me tromper et je
mange
alors le seigneur du 10 où certains
parce que tu as fait cela tu seras
maudit permis tous les animaux et toutes
les bêtes des champs tu rentreras sur le
rang et tu mangeras de l'abbatiale pour
les jours de ta vie je mettrai une
hostilité entre toi et la femme
entre-temps descendance et sa
descendance celle ci demeure triera la
terre et toi tu lui meurtrir a le talent
l'homme à plat sa femme et c'est à dire
la vivent
parce qu'il fut la mère de tous les
vivants le seigneur du fis à l'homme et
à sa femme des tuniques de peau et les
enrobés stif match comme un match m dos
des mots parole du seigneur
[Musique]
car demain
des enfants de cuivre
c
que ton
ce phare à 38
au cri de un coup
[Musique]
si tu me tiens
fauteux sait
c'est mieux
keystone
mais près de toi ce trou
le port
pour que l'homme
te
[Musique]
à
j'espère le seigneur de tout le monde
je laisse pas et je te sens
on m'attend
le sel
mais que meilleur hockey est
[Musique]
oui très du seigneur
près d abobo
celui qui achète
de tout c'est vous
[Musique]
e
il ya comme dans koh lanta vont être
contents oui j'ai menti
oui alors la première lecture ont évoqué
la faute ce dont on parle depuis
quelques jours
et le psaume dépend s'il se retient la
frontière
qui subsistera
qu'est ce qu'elle est d'accord alors
d'entrer dans l'avenir oui nous sommes
pêcheurs
le rite int en ciel de évoquée
mais il faut aller au delà de ça
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le seigneur soit avec vous
évangile de jésus christ en hausse et
l'udc
le même jour
c'est à dire le premier jour de la
semaine
deux disciples faisait route vers un
village appelé emmaüs à deux heures de
marche de jérusalem et ils parlaient
entre eux de tout ce qui c'était passé
or tandis qu'il s'entretenait et
s'interrogeait jésus lui-même s'approcha
et il marchait ai vécu mais leurs yeux
étaient empêchés de le reconnaître
jésus leur dit de quoi discuter vous en
marche
alors ils s'arrêtèrent tous tristes le
des deux nommés cléophas lui répondit
c'est bien le seul étranger résidant à
jérusalem
qui ignore les événements de ces jours
ci il leur dit quel événement
ils lui répondirent ce qui est arrivé à
jésus de nazareth
cet homme qui était un prophète puissant
par ses actes et ses paroles devant dieu
et devant tout le peuple comment les
grands brède et nos chefs l'ont livré
ils l'ont fait condamner à mort et l'ont
crucifié
nous nous espérions que c'était lui qui
allait délivrer israël
mais avec tout cela
voici déjà le troisième jour qui passe
depuis que c'est arrivé
à vrai dire des femmes de notre groupe
nous ont rempli de stupeur quand dès
l'aurore elles sont allées au tombeau
elles n'ont pas trouvé son corps
elles sont venues nous dire qu'elle
avait eu une vision des anges qui disait
qu'il est vivant
quelques-uns de nos compagnons sont
allés au tombeau ils ont trouvé les
choses comme les femmes l'avait dit mais
lui ne l'ont pas vu
il leur dit alors
esprit sans intelligence
comme votre coeur est là à croire tout
ce que les prophètes ont dit
ne fallait il pas que le christ souffrit
cela pour entrer dans sa gloire
et partant de moïse et de tous les
prophètes hilare interpréta dans toute
l'écriture ce qui le concernait
quand ils s'approchèrent du village où
il se rendait
jésus fit semblant d'aller plus loin
mais ils s'efforcèrent de le retenir
reste avec nous car le soir approche et
déjà le jour baisse
il entra donc pour rester avec eux
a clairement la parole de dieu
le viager
et lui a pris dès lors si si pour love
emmaus finale de l'évent celle de
l'évangile de saint luc on a eu marre et
illustre nos cheminement personnel et
celui de l'église
sur le chemin de la vie et de la vie
deux fois tandis que nous poursuivons
les rêves les projets les attentes et
les espérances qui habite notre coeur
nous nous heurtons à nos fragilités à
nos faiblesses
nous éprouvons des défaites et des
désillusions et parfois bloqueurs nous
restons prisonniers d'un sentiment
d'échec non pas là lui qui nous paralyse
l'évangile nous annonce néanmoins qu'à
ce moment précis nous ne sommes pas
seuls
le seigneur vient à notre rencontre
il marche à nos côtés
discret comme un voyageur aimable et
désireux de rouvrir notre nos yeux et de
raviver la flamme de notre coeur quand
les chèques s'efface devant la rencontre
avec le seigneur la vie renaît grâce à
l'espérance nous pouvons nous
réconcilier avec nous avec nos frères
nos soeurs et avec dieu
à
la fin de la manche et de ses 2 est une
image personnes de notre look
personnelle et de celle de lévis
sur chenilles la vie
et de l'avis de fois tandis que nous
poursuivons les rêves les projets les
attentes et les espérances qui évite
notre cas nous nous heurtons aussi à nos
fragilités ya nos faiblesses nous
exprimer expérimentons défaite et
d'illusions et parfois nous restons
prisonniers du sentiment d'échec qui
nous par avis
l'évangile nous annonce que précisément
à ce moment là nous nous sommes aussi
le seigneur viennent à notre rencontre
se jouait à nous marchent sur la même
route que nous avec la discrétion d'un
voyageur aimable qui veulent ouvrir nos
yeux et embrasé de nouveau notre coeur
et quand les chèques laisse place à la
rencontre avec le seigneur la vie renaît
à l'espérance et nous pouvons nous
réconcilier avec nous mêmes avec nos
frères avec dieu
si gamme en élite i know you d'été
camille je vends donc ce chemin qui
pourrait abriter la rose a plaidé l'
fracasso à la chèque à l'espérance et
elle commence à ce sentiment grisant
carrasso qui habite le score de 6-2
perella mois après la mort de jésus a
bien percé ils ont soutenu savez
poursuit un rêve avec fiat à bientôt
j'espère qu'ils avaient mis tous les
soirs et tous leurs désirs de la can
trois mois le pen après sa mort
scandaleux a fait la parade une semaine
il tourne le dos à jersey pour
et reprendre leur vie toujours des
chaumières et des voyages et un voyage
en gironde hydara comme citoyen
d'oublier qu'il s'agit là relâchement
leur d'amertume mais si à cette
expérience du messie crucifié comme un
malfaiteur women à gaza ils rentrent
chez eux a battu en simple un tetris et
la spectateurs mais attend qu'ils
avaient soulevé dans le néant cette
place à leur histoire était basé le
souhait auquel ils aspirent elles déjà
fait place à la décision du relais à
lamy le voleur
suivons donc l'itinéraire de ce chemin
que nous pourrions appeler de l'échec à
l'espérance
avant tout il ya le sentiment de l'échec
qui habite le coeur de ces 2,18 après la
mort de jésus
il avait poursuivi un rat est avec
enthousiasme
en jésus il avait mis toutes leurs
espérances et tous leurs désirs
maintenant après la mort scandaleux saut
à croire il tourne le dos à jérusalem
pour rentrer chez eux à la vie d'avant
leur voyage est un voyage de retour
comme pour vouloir oublier cette
expérience qui a rempli d'amertume leur
coeur ce messie miam en commun comme un
malfaiteur ce à quoi
ils rentrent chez eux abbas eut toute
liste les attentes qu'ils avaient
cultivé sont tombés dans lire
les espérances en l'acquittant lesquels
il avait cru ont été brisé les rêves
qu'ils auraient voulu réaliser laisse
place à la déception est à l'amertume
mais tel qu'heuliez qui atteignent est à
même oui cela nous arrive aussi dans
notre vie alc avait dans notre
cheminement spirituel
sens à toute occasion qu'ils existent à
modifier nos attentes et rétive et à
faire face au but aux ambiguïtés de la
réalité qu'on la forme elle avait été
maire de la ville à nos faiblesses et
samo qui énonce ou cv cela m'est arrivé
à chaque fois que nos idées on a fait se
heurte aux désillusions de la ville il
n'est que nos intentions calmer les
sombres dans le
lot fragilité qu'on ait récemment
lorsque le sang des jeunes ont des
projets de biens et manque à passer dans
l'ain campe est l'incapacité
lorsque dans le 4 2 aux algues vertes
est un embryon
nous avons tous larre une défaite mais
une ride un échec ou une substance ou cv
lorsque nous voyons ces faits bris d'un
stage en quoi ap nous avions cru look et
karimouche aux coloris envers crois que
nous étions engagés à même d'orienter et
que nous voyons plus de moi d'un pc et
d'un sentiment de culpabilité
c'est une expérience qui concerne aussi
notre vie et notre cheminement spirituel
en tout six occasions où nous sommes
contre et de redimensionner nos attentes
et de faire face aux ambiguïtés de la
réalité aux ténèbres de la vie à nos
faiblesses
cela nous arrive chaque fois que nous
idéaux se heurte aux délices du aux
désillusions de la vie et que nos
intentions sont ignorés à cause de nos
fragilités
lorsque nous cultivons des projets de
bien mais que nous n'avons pas la
capacité de les mettre en oeuvre
lorsque dans les activités que nous
menons ou dans nos relations tota nous
faisons l'expérience d'une défaite d'une
erreur d'un échec ou d'une chute tandis
que nous voyons s'effondrer ce en quoi
nous avions conclu où nous étions
engagés
tandis que nous nous sentons écrasé par
notre péché et notre culpabilité
il est haut et fort qu'elle est sous ce
niveau là c'est arrivé avant hier ils
ont supprimé la lecture dans la première
lecture bkw non sur le salaire pc les a
éloignés c'est le nom d'un dieu et nous
les aussi l'un de l'autre ancien masse
au grand fossé ne cesse de se rejeter la
responsabilité des six poules nous
voyons aussi chez les disciples d'emmaüs
dans le manège et d'avoir vu s'écouler
le projet de jésus et pas sur le fait
place qu'à une discussion stérile
cela peut également se produire dans la
vie de l'église la communauté des
disciples du seigneur que représentent
les deux pèlerins démarrage et charles
dickens les ailes à combien qu'armand la
communauté du réseau 50 50 et c'est vrai
peut se sentir perdus et déçu face au
scandale du mal le lit de la violence du
val du calvaire qui d'un temps ce sont
les nocturnes en rien ses atouts marque
de s'accrocher à ce sentiment d'échec et
se demander que cette île facile de
vivre quoi et ça m'a fait beaucoup rire
comment cela at-il pu arriver seul aviva
d'ariel dans la première lecture
leur péché non seulement les éloigner
nos yeux mais les éloignés l'un de
l'autre
ils ne peuvent que s'accuser
mutuellement
ils nous le voyons s'il existe des
merlus dont le malaise d'avoir vu
s'écouler le projet de jésus ne laisse
place à une discussion stérile
et cela peut également se produire dans
la vie de l'église la communauté des
disciples du seigneur que les deux
disciples d'emmaüs représente bien
qu'étant la communauté du ressuscité
elle peut se trouver perdu et déçu
devant le scandale du mal et la violence
du calvaire
elle ne peut alors rien faire d'autre
que série dans ses mains le sentiment de
l'échec et se demander qu'est ce qui
s'est passé pourquoi cela est il arrivé
comment cela at il pu arriver
elle m'a nous firent manage sont très
rares c'est la question que nous nous
posons tout fonctionne et en inde et se
sont aussi là les interrogations brûle
en essai qui résonne dans le quart de
cette église en est rien à jouer dans
des salles 1 sur 7 et prévention de
guérison et de réconciliation d'un
mélenchon leur intérêt nous aussi face
au scandale du mal et et corps du christ
blessés dans la chair et d'os frères
autochtones et mon son mari dont nous
sommes vous plonger dans l'amertume en
selle et le ressentons le poids de
l'échec poehl may tamek mais on a pu
permettez moi alors devenir
intellectuellement nombreuses nouvelles
races empruntant ici le synthé scanner
vous qui rappelle la montée de jésus sur
au prétoire d'un malade qu'en y
permettez moi de vous êtes un plot ni en
tant qu'eglise dans ses interrogations
qui émane de coeur chargé de douleur
pourquoi toujours est il arrivé aux
commandes quelques sources ou cela at il
pu se produire dans la communauté de son
qg ce sont les questions que chacun se
pose à lui même et ce sont aussi les
interrogations brûlante que cette église
pèlerine sup au canada fait résonner
dans son cas sur un éprouvant chomel
guérison et de réconciliation que nous
réalisons
nous aussi face au scandale humain lié
au corps du christ blessés dans la chair
de nos frères autochtone nous sommes
plongés dans l'amertume et nous
ressentons le poids de l'échec de la
chute
permettez moi alors de munir
spirituellement aux nombreux pèlerins
qui parcourt ici la scala santa qui
évoque cette montée de jésus au prétoire
de pilates et vous accompagner en tant
qu'ils glissent dans ses interrogations
qui n'a as du coeur chargé de douleur
pourquoi tout cela est il arrivé
comment cela s'est plus produire dans la
communauté de ceux qui suivent jésus
il n'était point taux d'événements
sollicité deux fois à la tête du conseil
attentif à la tentation de la fuite
après certaines représentent les deux
pèlerins de l'évangile oui
des saphirs faire marche arrière
sur le lieu où les faits se sont
produits dans tarder que ça essayer de
les faire disparaître des communes maïs
cherchait un endroit tranquille pour ne
plus y penser
il n'y a rien de pire face au revers de
la vie que de fuir pour ne pas les
affronter ces tentations de lemmings
menace notre cheminement spirituel et la
marche de l'église elle veut nous faire
croire que cet échec et définitif qui
les paralyse à elle veut nous enfermer
dans ce sentiment d'amertume et de
tristesse
nous convaincre qu'il n'ya plus rien à
faire et que par conséquent il est
inutile de chercher une voie pour
recommencer
ici cependant nous devons être attentifs
à la tentation de la fuite présente chez
les deux ici de les venger
faire marche arrière
s'enfuir eu lieu où les faits se sont
produits
tenter de les enlever
cherchent un endroit tranquille comme
emmaüs pour ne plus y penser
il n'est en rien pire face aux échecs de
la vie que de fuir pour ne pas les
affronter c'est une tentation de
l'ennemi
qui menacent notre cheminement spirituel
et la marche de l'église
il veut nous faire croire que cet échec
est désormais définitif il veut nous
paralyser dans la mer se met dans la
tristesse nous convainc qu'il n'y a plus
rien à faire et que ça ne vaut donc pas
la peine de trouver une voie pour
recommencer
cinéma joue libéré le président qui
précise à mener une vie nouvelle et
venger son gagne c'est justement qu'on
frappe pour quelle désillusion et la
souffrance c'est précisément que nous
sommes sans voix c'est la violence du
mal face à la honte de la culpabilité
quand la rivière de nos vies est
asséchée par le péché nous les chutes au
camp nou pas laisser dépouiller de tours
qu'il ne nous croyons qu'il ne nous
reste plus rien et coin gauche c'est
précisément cet instant que les seniors
vient à notre rencontre
une gamine à nos côtés sur le chemin
d'emmaüs conduit s'approche doucement
homme qui comparative mon équipe on
s'est partagé la marche s'est résignée
de c'est d'ici qu'il a sein de chacun
nos frais c'est que fait-il
ils n'offrent pas des mots
d'encouragement creux il ne prononce pas
de paroles de circonstances invoquées ne
donne pas non plus de consolation c'est
facile mais plutôt il révèle à travers
les saintes écritures
le mystère de sa mort et de sa
résurrection
il jette sa lumière sur l'histoire et
les événements vécus
et leur ouvre les yeux de mal aux vins
qu'ils puissent poser sur le monde un
regard nouveau peuvent nous aussi ici
qui partageons l'eucharistie en cette
basilique nous pouvons faire une
relecture de bien des événements de
l'histoire ici même et non une trois
temples se sont déjà succédé mais ici
même aussi il ya eu des personnes qui
n'ont pas reculé face aux embûches qui
ont su rêver à nouveau malgré les
erreurs se signent leurs erreurs et
celle des autres ainsi quand il ya 100
ans un incendie a ravagé le sanctuaire
ils n'ont pas baissé les bras et ils ont
reconstruit cette basilique avec courage
et créativité et tous ceux qui partagent
avec nous l'eucharistie depuis les
plaines d'abraham tout près d'ici là les
mots peuvent aussi le ressentir cet élan
de ceux qui ne se sont pas laissés
enfermer par la haine et de la guerre de
la destruction de la souffrance ce
qu'ils ont subi au contraire réimpr
imaginez une ville un pays que
précisément dans les situations de
d'illusions et de douleur
précisément lorsque nous expérimentons
avec stupéfaction la violence du mal et
la honte de la faute lorsque le fleuve
de notre vie se dessèchent à cause du
péché et dans les chais quand dépouillé
de tout il nous semble que nous n'avons
plus rien
précisément là le seigneur vient à notre
rencontre et marchent avec nous
sur le chemin d'emmaüs il se joue elle
existe gression pour accompagner et
partager les pros résigné de ses
disciples triste est que fixe il ils
n'offrent pas des paroles
d'encouragement générique d expression
circonstances des consommations facile
mais en dévoilant dans les saintes
écritures
le mystère de sa mort et de sa
résurrection
il éclaire leur histoire et les
événements qui l'ont vécue
ainsi ils ouvrent leurs yeux un nouveau
regard sur les choses
nous aussi qui partageons l'eucharistie
dans cette base il et nous pouvons le
lire de nombreux événements de
l'histoire
sur ce même lieu il y avait auparavant
trois temples il y avait ceux qui n'ont
pas fui devant les difficultés
qui ont rêvé de nouveau malgré leurs
erreurs et ceux des autres ils ne se
sont pas laissés vaincre par le terrible
incendie de ce sanctuaire et avec
courage et créativité ils sont
reconstruits ce temps et ceux qui
partagent le quart ici depuis les
plaines d'abraham
peuvent aussi sentir l'âme de ceux qui
ne se sont pas laissés prendre en otage
par la haine de la guerre
à part la destruction et par la douleur
météo sur nouveau projeté une ville et
un pays
finalement tu es en théorie un peu lourd
sous les yeux des pèlerins d'emmaüs par
des vans les huées rond le pas et
montagne leur ouvre les yeux mondiaux et
se montre à nouveau
comme le dieu d'amour qui donne sa vie
pour ses amis
il leur permet de reprendre la route
dans la joie de repartir de passer de
l'échec à l'espérance humans et les
frères mes soeurs
le seigneur veut faire de même avec
chacun de nous avec son église
comment pouvons nous ouvrir les yeux à
nouveau la main comment notre coeur
peut-il s'enflammer à nouveau pour les
vengeurs nous appliquions que faire
quand nous nous lamentons face aux
épreuves spirituel et matériel
quand nous cherchons le chemin vers une
société mais de justin morel plus
fraternelle quand nous aspirons à nous
remettre de nos déceptions de la paix
rhdp cuisse main quand nous cherchons à
guérir des blessures du passé continuez
à nous réconcilier avec dieu et avec les
autres devant les disciples d'emmaüs
j'ai sûr on le paye rouvrant leurs yeux
et se montra encore une fois comme le
dieu de l'amour qui donne sa vie pour
ses amis
de cette manière il les a aidé à
reprendre le chemin avec joie à
recommencer à passer de l'échec à
l'espérance
frères et soeurs le seigneur veut faire
de même avec chaque noeud et avec son
église
comment nous supporter tilt est rouvert
comment notre coeur peut-il encore
s'embraser pour l'évent gier
que faire lorsque nous sommes affligés
par diverses épreuves spirituelles et
matérielles
lorsque nous cherchons la voie vers une
société plus juste et fraternelle
lorsque nous désirons nous remette de
nos déceptions nos facs et lorsque nous
espérons guérir des blessures du passé
il nous réconcilier avec sur et entre
solo vaio x men où il n'y a qu'un seul
chemin une seule fois en dessous c'est
la voix de geste communiqué soumis ce
chemin c'est jésus lui-même
croyons le jésus se joint à nous sur
notre chemin qui sont le nous rejoindre
laissons sa parole interpréter
l'histoire celle que nous vivons une en
tant qu'individu latine en tant que
communauté
laissons sa parole nous montrer le
chemin de la réconciliation fait et
partageons dans la fois le pain de
l'eucharistie pour des mots car autour
de la table nous pourrons nous
reconnaître en fils bien-aimé du père
tous appelés à être frères
jésus en rompant le pain confirme le
témoignage des phares nous bien que les
disciples n'avait pas cru qu'il est
ressuscité et netto si lippi dans cette
basilique
nous rendons grâce à la mère de la
vierge marie temps où se trouve aussi
une crypte dédié à l'immaculée
conception d'éléments comme chantal
peuple tous nous devons nous souvenir du
rôle que dieu a voulu donner aux femmes
dans son plan pour le celi sainte anne
la très sainte vierge marie des femmes
du matin de ban et nous montre sur un
nouveau chemin de réconciliation la
tendresse maternelle de tant de femmes
pagnol qu'on peut nous accompagner c'est
dans l'église vers des temps qui seront
à nouveau effectuer mon sac des temps
nous laisserons dernière nous toute
cette stérilité tout sept morts des
dents ou jésus elle que le crucifié
ressuscité
retrouvera sa place hawthorne aucune ce
good or ce chemin
si le mail jésus c'est le chemin qu'est
jésus
croyons que jésus se jouer à notre
marche et laissons-nous rencontrées par
lui
laissons sa parole interpréter
l'histoire que nous vivons comme
individu et comme communauté et nous
indiquer la voie pour guérir et pour
nous réconcilier
jean pons ensemble avec fois le pain
eucharistique
afin que autour de ces tables nous
puissions nous redécouvrir enfants bien
aimés du père appelait à être tous faire
jésus à rompre le pain confirme ce que
les disciples ont déjà reçu comme
témoignages des femmes et à qui ils
n'ont pas voulu croire qu'il est
ressuscité
dans cette basilique
où nous rappelons où nous nous rappelons
de la mère de la vierge marie et où se
trouve également la crypte étiez à
l'immaculée conception
nous ne pouvons que souligner le rôle
que tu as voulu donner à la femme dans
son plan de salut
cinq ans la très sainte vierge marie
les femmes du matin de pâques nous
indique une nouvelle voie de
réconciliation
la tendresse maternelle de nombreuses
femmes peut nous accompagner commis
glisse vers des temps à nouveau fait
qu'on où nous laissons derrière nous
tant de stérilité et nous remettrons au
centre j'ai su le crucifié ressuscité
des jo
et enfin au coeur de nos questions alors
que j'aime la mode est au coeur des
tâches d'une pause totale au coeur de la
vie pastorale même
ne pouvons pas nous placer nous mêmes
nos frustrations
c'est lui le seigneur jésus qui est au
centre là au coeur de chaque chose une
place en sa parole qui jette sa lumière
sur les événements et nous rend la vue
pour voir la pressant présence efficace
de l'amour de dieu vienne et la
possibilité du bien même lorsque la
situation semble vraiment désespère
tournament la sonde même au centre le
pain de l'eucharistie qu jésus rond pour
nous aujourd'hui encore pour partager sa
vie avec l'annoncé en brasse et nos
faiblesses soutenir non pas fatigué et
guérir nos 48 heures qu'on use alors y
ont signé avec dieu avec les hommes avec
nous mêmes nous aussi nous pourrons nous
faire instrument de réconciliation et de
paix mis dans la société dans laquelle
nous vivons en effet au centre de nos
questions des peines que nous portons en
nous de la vie pastorale m
nous pouvons pas nous santé sur nous
mêmes et nos échecs
nous devons nous santé sur lui le
seigneur jésus au coeur de toute chose
mettons sa parole qui éclaire les
événements et nous rend la vue pour
déceler la présence agissante de l'amour
de dieu et la possibilité du bien même
dans des situations apparemment terre
sur
mettons le pen le cas ici que j'ai
jurons aujourd'hui encore pour nous pour
partager sa vie avec la l'autre
embrasser nos faiblesses
soutenir nos peaux fatiguées et nous
donner la guérison du coeur
et réconcilier avec dieu avec les autres
et avec nous mêmes
nous pouvons nous aussi
devenir des instruments de
réconciliation et de paix dans la
société dans laquelle nous vivons
sign on le fait sous ce seigneur jésus
nous tuer notre chemin vers notre force
et notre consolation ils ont zappé nous
nous adressons à toi russie pour lever
tout comme les pèlerins d'emmaüs
reste avec nous car le soir approche et
déjà le jour baisse reste avec nos
seigneurs rim quand l'espérance
s'aménuisent et tombe sur nous la nuit
noire de la déception qu'on reste avec
nous jésus car avec toi notre sentier
emprunte une nouvelle direction et
depuis les voies sans issues de la
méfiance
relais l'émerveillement de la joie
qu'il était contre reste avec nos
seniors avec toi la nuit de la douleur
se fait au bras dieuze de vie simple
mais simplement nous le disons qu'il
reste avec nous seniors que sutton
famelart si tu marches à nos côtés à
moto lors le feu alors l'échelle s'ouvre
sur l'espérance d'une ville nouvelle à
bâle urgent de
notre faune notre chemin
notre force et notre consolation
nous nous adressons à toi comme les
disciples d'emmaüs
reste avec nous car le soir approche
reste avec nous seigneur quand
l'espérance se couche et que la nuit la
déception décline
reste avec nous parce qu'avec toi jésus
le cours des événements changent et
l'émerveillement de la joie renaît de
l'impasse du découragement
reste avec nous seigneur car avec toi la
nuit de la douleur se change en matière
à dieu de la vie
nous disons simplement
reste avec nous seigneur parce que si tu
marches à nos côtés l'échec sourd à
l'espérance d'une vie nouvelle
un maire
demande d'excusés demander pardon
dieu est toujours à l'écouté des besoins
des femmes et des hommes de notre temps
ces moments particuliers les prières et
de loin son signe que s'introduit
lessines tensions avec des soupes qui
nous accompagne sur l'euro de la vie
après chez détention nous répondrons
seigneur quant à notre prière
pour notre part françois que son
ministère apporte au moment de réconfort
de la bonne nouvelle
inauguré par le christ et prions le
seigneur
attend matériel
j'aime jours
[Musique]
venise a réagi aux
deux têtes monde et avec
mahmoud thiam qui avait tourné 2010 qui
m'a dit madame plus que peur quand même
pour les populations autochtones et pour
notre nation de des paroles et des
justes jeunes une obligation
on a tremblé rio ni à la table le
christie je fais les communions et la
parole à l'onyx traîne avec hommes
jeunes ou des artisans de paix et
d'amour dans les lieux où nous vivons et
travaillons prions nous allions
perdre ou saint
thois envoyer ton fils l'allemand peut
manifester la montée est ta miséricorde
à tous les
admirateurs
écoute notre pierre et c'est pour cela
par l'église nos seniors
j'ai
juste appris
noatun
city
[Musique]
m
oh
à
et ne
et
vous
me aubut
et
aurélie et au moins c'est un lien
sachet
nous
connaissons à château moman
[Musique]
on a
n'hésitez
minitel au qatar
[Musique]
madonna
show men impôts locaux
torino
aïe aïe
edwards
principal
sa jeunesse comme au mérite et incognito
à
chameau
[Musique]
si nous développons darwin ou
wes
capacité
à nous t'aimer
le
[Musique]
capital
émis loupé
shimano
[Musique]
aussi malick
diop au sein et à mai s'est déroulé
n'était
le 6 mai
chicanes amopa
stein co
et rooney ont ajouté
[Musique]
et c'est
teddy chevalier
[Musique]
des rondes
st
au yacht et
william hamouri
est mauvais et me
dit tu dois
audio est bonne
dis toi j'ai chaud mot
chaque à ces dames
le projet est mis à cogner
non
[Musique]
frères et soeurs pris ensemble au moment
d'offrir le sacrifice de toute l'église
rappelle toi seigneur ton fait c'est
notre terre et notre réconciliation
par son sang il a enlevé le péché du
monde
accueille avec monter les dons de ton
église
heureuse de célébrer ce temps de grâce
donne nous de pouvoir apporter à tous la
liberté du christ lui qui vit et règne
pour les siècles des siècles
le seigneur soit avec vous
[Musique]
élevons notre que
rendant grâce au seigneur notre dieu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vraiment il est juste et bon de te
rendre grâce et de chanter ta louange de
dieu le père tout puissant
pour l'oeuvre que tu accomplis dans ce
monde par notre seigneur jésus le christ
au sein de notre humanité encore désuni
et déchiré nous savons d'expérience que
tu changes les cars et les prépare à la
réconciliation
ton esprit travail le quart des sommes
pour que les ennemis se parlent à
nouveau
les adversaires se tend de la mer et que
les peuples cherchent à se rencontrer
oui c'est en oeuvre seigneur quand
l'amour l'emportent sur la haine quand
la vengeance fait place au pardon et la
discorde se change en amitié
c'est pourquoi
unis eau car céleste qui tu chantes nous
ne cessons de te rendre grâce et sur la
terre nous proclamons sans fin ta gloire
ça
[Musique]
et
e
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
père tout puissant nous bénissons par
jésus-christ ton fils
venu dans notre monde en ton nom
il est la parole du salut pour les
hommes la main que tu rends que tu t'en
aux pêcheurs le chemin par où nous
arrive la paix que tu donnes
alors que nos péchés nous avait détourné
de toi seigneur ce nous a conduits à la
réconciliation
pour que tourner vers toi nous nous
aimions les uns les autres par ton fils
que tu as livré pour nous à la mort
et maintenant que nous célébrons la
réconciliation que le christ nous a
obtenu nous te prions
sanctifie ses offrandes en répandant sur
l ton esprit qu'elle devienne le corps
et le sang de ton fils qui nous a dit de
célébrer ce mystère
au cours du repas qu'il allait lui qui
allait donner sa vie pour notre
libération il prit le pain dans ses
mains et rendre grâce il dit la
bénédiction il rompit le père et le
donna à ses disciples en disant prenez
et mangez en tous ceci est mon corps
livré pour vous
de même ce soir là
il prit danser mais la coupe de
bénédiction en proclamant ta miséricorde
puis il donna la coop ac dc en disant
prenez et buvez en tous car ceci est la
coupe de mon sens le sens de l'alliance
nouvelle et éternelle qui sera versée
pour vous et pour la multitude en
rémission des péchés
vous ferez cela en mémoire de moi
[Musique]
il est grand le mystère de la foi
coût
[Musique]
en
faisant taissy mémoire de la mort et de
la résurrection de ton fils qui nous a
laissé un tel gage de son amour nous te
présentons cette offrande qui vient de
toi le sacrifice de la parfaite
réconciliation
est redressée note en supplions
accueillis nous avec ton fils est dans
ce repas qui nous sauve accord de nous
son esprit qu'il fasse disparaître les
causes de nos divisions
de ce même esprit passe devant l'église
les hommes est l'instrument de ta paix
ils nous gardent en communion avec notre
pape françois émond frères évêques
gérald évêque de cette église de québec
pour moi même ton humble serviteur avec
l'ensemble de mes frères évêques et ton
peuple tout entier
et comme tu nous a réunis maintenant à
la table de ton fils rassemble nous un
jour auprès de la glorieuse vierge marie
mère de dieu avec tes bienheureuse
apôtres et tous les saints avec nos
frères et soeurs
avec les hommes et les femmes de toutes
origines et de toutes langues qui sont
morts dans ton amitié ce jour-là
rassemble nous au banquet de l'unité a
jamais à on plie dans les cieux nouveaux
et la terre nouvelles ou resplendit en
plénitude de la paix qui vient de toi
dans le christ jésus notre seigneur
par lui avec lui et en lui
à toi tu la perds tout puissant dans
l'unité du saint-esprit
tout honneur et toute gloire pour les
siècles des siècles
[Musique]
oh
non
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
unis dans le même esprit nous pouvons
dire avec confiance la prière que nous
avons reçu du sauveur
notre père qui est aux cieux que ton nom
soit sanctifié que ton règne vienne
que ta volonté
sur la terre dans mon siège ce ne nous
aujourd'hui notre gré de ce lot par nous
nos offenses comme nous pardonnons aussi
à ceux qui nous ont offensés et ne nous
laisse pas entrer en tentation mais
délivre nous du mal
des livres nous de tout mal seigneur et
donne la paix à notre teint
soutenu par ta miséricorde nous serons
libérés de tout péché à l'abri de toute
épreuve nous qui attendons que se
réalise cette bienheureuse espérances
l'avènement de jésus-christ notre
sauveur
seigneur jésus-christ tu as dit à tes
apôtres je vous laisse la paix je vous
donne ma paie
ne regarde pas nos péchés mais la foi de
ton église pour que ta volonté sa
complice de nuit toujours cette paix et
conduit là vers l'unité parfaite toi qui
vit et règne pour les siècles des
siècles
que la paix du seigneur soit toujours
avec vous
et
[Musique]
la poupée
merci
[Musique]
donc de retour avec genou routier
on va en voir revenir bien sûr sur le
mélies tape françois un peu plus tard
mais procède de ce moment là pour
quelques notes explicatives d'abord il
ya beaucoup
se jouer par labatt année par lequel s
utilisé pour la cérémonie d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
mon rythme
alors effectivement il a parlé beaucoup
de l'histoire et les derniers jours nous
ont rappelé cette histoire cette
histoire souvent douloureuse mais c'est
unique à québec nous la célébration se
fait avec des vases liturgique qui ont
été remis à françois de laval qui date
du xviie siècle la croix de procession a
été utilisé pour la première fois en
1766 lors de la consécration de la
cathédrale
il ya le calice et la patène également
acquis ont été remis à françois de laval
et du monde heureux les invités au repas
des noces de l'agneau seigneur je ne
suis pas et ne recevra lundi seulement
qu'une
hariri
voilà
bon
il
[Musique]
quelques points d'information avec mes
invités sur le plateau d'abord aller au
champ sociologue des religions présence
de langue autochtone dans cette
élévation effectivement rien moments
importants or au moment où on it suit
donc le repas autour de la tente et à la
rencontre je pense est significatif que
ça a été choisi on ne lâche pas c'est un
moment intéressant et je trouve aussi on
entendu le pape entre en scène
aujourd'hui oui effectivement le pape en
français et toute la liturgie s'est
déployée en français alors que m anton
on s'en souvient tout la prière
eucharistique avait été en latin ce
qu'on a évité cette fois ci on a pris
les langues
vulgaire si on peut dire
les langues modernes
quand on pourra revient sur un l'homélie
du pape mais je profite de ces moments
là pour
pour c'est que au delà de l'homélie
pinon on n'a pas entendu formellement
lui demander pardon aussi
mais au delà ça dans le choix des
lectures là aussi on passe aussi des
messages
et en gros le programme rituel est le
suivant on arrive et on est rassemblé
mais on arrive dans un lieu dans un
sanctuaire de tous les horizons avec nos
histoires avec nos espérances nous
blessures et la première chose que l'on
fait on dit nous sommes pêcheurs nous le
peuple de dieu alors c'est le raid
pénitentielle qui ouvre la célébration
et ensuite on se réunit autour d'une
première table où c'est la parole qui
est partagée parole entre nous et parole
de dieu qui n'est qui est proclamé et là
on a commencé par la faute nous sommes
nous avons succombé
à la fin
nous sommes pêcheurs
et puis
andy dans le psaume mais s'il se retient
de fautes y ont rien à faire notre
histoire est foutu on va être dans
l'amertume on va être dans la
culpabilité tout le reste de notre vie
on peut devenir possible si tu résides
vos fautes qui donc subsistera
et ensuite on va à l'évangile le récit
de ces deux désespérés parce qu'ils
avaient connu un échec terrible et leurs
espérances et est tombé dans le néant
et de là on va passer à l'autre table
oui une espérance possible et
l'espérance et quoi l'espérance c'est
con comme unis au maire
qu'on soit devenu autour de même temps
comme des frères et soeurs et c'est ça
la réconciliation et vos médias au
moment où
l'égalité oui pis à l'extérieur ce n'est
pas qu'à l'intérieur de la basilique oui
mais à l'extérieur également pour les
milliers personnes qui sont réunis sur
sur le parvis
des mouchards
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on vide
qu'est ce que on a entendu des paroles
on entendu l'homélie du pape sur
lesquels ne vous inquiétez pas on va
revenir mais dans l'histoire dans
l'étude des religions qui votre
spécialité qu'est ce qu'on vit pas ce
qu'on vit présentement c'est en oublie
souvent qu'une religion c'est un univers
de sens et que on lit
l'actualité en lit la réalité à partir
de cet univers de sens et ce qu'on voit
actuellement c'est ça ce que nous offre
l'église catholique par cette messe
s'est tout à coup un message et langil à
bienne la bière expliquer un peu à la
naissance de ce message là
mais donc on oublie souvent que ça
paraisse par ce registre là et ça peut
ça peut-être que ça nous un poste
qu'elle un peu on n'est pas habitué à ce
type de discours actuellement il ya des
gens qui probablement s'attendait à ce
que le pape prononçait des paroles comme
un pdg d'une compagnie cas ce n'est pas
ça c'est pas ça s'est passé à lille ici
avec un message dont il est le porteur
et pas seulement lui mais toute la
communauté pied là et où il offre une
clé de lecture à ce qui s'est passé et
est ce qui s'en vient et parce que c'est
ça qu'il faut retenir de ce qu'on voit
actuellement et ça c'est typique au
phénomène religieux et comme on a perdu
un peu à dinde de culture religieuse
rapport au religieux bail est peut-être
déjà qu'ils sont inconfortables sasa
saoudite au moins qui sont surpris mais
à moi ce que je retiens c'est sur un bon
exemple de comment tout à coup
contrairement aux discours qui circulent
et ça ça même à partir de 12 de
l'homélie on peut aller chercher un sens
ailleurs dans une autre façon de voir
les choses et c'est pour ça que le rôle
qu'a joué le religieux dans toute
l'histoire de l'humanité c'est aussi je
repense à ce que vient dire avec chars
c'est pas le pdg une compagnie qui s
adresser aux retards qu'ils
dürer nous inclus là dedans lorsqu'on
dit on attend les demandes de pardon les
demandes excuses puis l'inclût pour
l'église
n'oublions pas que le pape par l'entente
conscient parabole prix qu'il faut puis
là je vais utiliser l'expression lire
entre les lignes parce qu'il ya puis on
voit les décortiquer tout à l'heure dans
son homélie ya une foule de messages qui
bon les jeunes ne le savent pas mais on
discute et vous m'expliquez durant
l'homélie certains passages où ans qui
sont doit comprendre alors foufoune nous
qui sommes là écoutez il faut se mettre
dans cette perspective nous de dire oh
attention
c'est le pam qui parlent ils pas aussi
en paraboles et le crip nous travail
c'est-à-dire fait nous normalement on
sort de ce lot différent de quand on est
entrés
parce que on a fini par comme 2010 à ces
chemins
non seulement des peuples autochtones
mais c'est le chemin de l'église on
était
séparés les uns des autres on était sans
avenir
et comment on peut déverrouiller quelque
chose est ce que cette semaine n'en peux
plus je reviens encore à la thématique
de la parabole si l'adq on y est ce que
cette semaine un
peu à être espèce de marche à suivre que
souhaite le pape bauthéac est bonne on
dira ça a été vite il a demandé pardon
par la suite se voit sur le chemin de la
réconciliation il a aujourd'hui dans un
anneau midi nous explique comment se
réconcilier
ça s'est passé tête en une semaine mais
pour lui c'est la marche à suivre
peut-être pour les dix prochaines années
à l'image de cette semaine mais trop
rapidement sans doute mais il ya des
contraintes de temps ouais mais comment
on passe
l'aveu des fontes
j'ai honte mais je suis pénitents je te
demande pardon
et ensuite de dire de cela on va aller
jusqu'à être en sangles et ouvrir
désormais un chemin nouveau être autour
de la même table on va communier au même
point alors passer d'eux
j'ai chuté
et celle semaines l'église ou si c'est
pas simplement celui des autochtones
c'est le chemin de l'église
si la réconciliation ces deux éléments
donc c'est pas simplement les
autochtones c'est ya un bout de chemin à
faire pour l'église de se réconcilier
le seigneur
nous avons reçu les sacs à main des
temps fils dénoncent des pions signaux
kg mènent nos fausses et nous donne des
puits c'est dans ce mystère l'unité
l'amour authentic différa dénombre quant
au lieu de satisfaire de la paix qui est
bien de toi par l'actrice du seigneur
très saint père
sharp et françois
merci d'être avec nous tu es devenu
jusqu'à nous marcher avec nous
jésus nous a fait une puissante leçon de
pédagogie
lorsqu'il se joint à la marche des deux
disciples
désenchanté sur le chemin d'emmaüs
comprenant leur désarroi il prend la
route avec eux ils écoutent leurs
doléances
il éclaire leur foi jusqu'à la
révélation de sa présence par le geste
qui les propulse vers la mission
jésus leur devient invisible
soudainement
laissant à l'esprit c'est le soin de les
accompagner vers la vérité tout entière
le seigneur a pensé en panser leurs
plaies et apaiser leurs désillusions
il a changé le sens de leur existence
et infléchir la trajectoire de leur vie
en les dirigeant vers ceux et celles qui
sont en quête d'un message d'espérance
pour vivre dans la dignité d'enfants de
dieu
vous voici au québec
très saint père
précisément en ce sanctuaire de sainte
anne de beaupré
marchant sur les chemins cas foulée il y
a près de trois siècles et demi notre
premier et vaillante et vainquit pasteur
saint françois de laval saint françois
de québec
sa mission a été poursuivi par des
myriades de disciples missionnaires
venus de tous les horizons
et brûlant du même feu sacré d'annoncer
l'évangile en cette terre d'amérique
en dépit de réalisation exceptionnelle
les routes ont été parsemées d'embûches
éclaboussant la beauté du message
évangélique
des scandales ont éclaté
des divisions se sont opérés la fois 7 à
faty
un puissant appel à la guérison et à la
réconciliation
7le élevé des coeurs et de vie meurtri
comme une tempête dans l'écho a résonné
jusqu'à vous
vous avez entendu les récriminations et
reconnu la gravité et comme lemaitre
d'emmaüs
vous avez pris la route pour venir
marcher avec nous sur le chemin de la
guérison et de la réconciliation
ensemble nous engageons une démarche
d'ouverture à nos réalités particulières
en reconnaissant bien humblement nos
défaillances
mais surtout nous cherchons les remèdes
capable non seulement d'extirper le mal
à sa racine
mais de mener nos communautés assoiffé
de justice
d'unité et de paix vers une guérison
complète
tant de personnes vous doivent le plus
sincère reconnaissance
celles qui sont ici rassemblés et celles
qui vous accompagne tout au long de
votre pèlerinage en notre terre
canadienne
mais en premier lieu
nos frères et nos soeurs des premières
nations les métis et les inuits de chez
nous
votre profonde et sincère sollicitude
procure un baume pour la guérison de
profondes blessures et un élan
nécessaire dans le processus de
réconciliation
tellement bénéfique pour la paix
nous savons très saint père
que les résultats attendus ne peuvent
survenir du jour au lendemain ils
exigent de formidables dose de
résilience
de geste sincère d'accueil et d'empathie
par votre présence au milieu de nous
vous démontrez que nulle effort n'est
utile que toute démarche de
réconciliation
exige une part importante de renoncement
une forte dose d'humilité de
compréhension et d'ouverture à la vie et
à la culture des autres
merci de nous accompagner sur la route
de la guérison et de la réconciliation
merci de prier pour nous
comme nous vous assurons nous mêmes de
vous accompagner le mieux possible sur
la route de votre exigeante mission
merci chère terre pâtes françois provost
mots et vosges est encourageant et
interpellant
nous aurons bien le goût de vous dire
comme les disciples d'emmaüs à jésus
reste avec nous mais nous savons que
votre présence de pasteur est attendu
ailleurs ou d'autres frères et soeurs
ont besoin d'être
réconforté et confirmés dans leur foi
bonne route très saint père
buendia et santo pavé et puis les
comptes a reconnu est la somme il des
sceaux rationnel est et poèmes lolo qui
est des îles nécessita dessaoulé dès la
seconde il est sous testimonio des faits
que jésus veille sur vous
ainsi que sa mère la vierge marie et sa
grand-mère la bonne sainte anne
[Musique]
nos frères et soeurs anglophone vous
dise du fond du car finck you or if
havre les wendat vous dise tu y as one
inc les innu tahin hqe ou meetings les
in winter n'a cormick
l'écrit me gouache les attikameks me
traitez
moi je vous dis au nom de la grande
famille que nous formons de tous car et
avec toute notre reconnaissance
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est hier
que les noms de ces unions soi mais ni
on sait qu'il est un élan de signaux
un bon tennis les pères des fils et le
saint-esprit
là
[Musique]
et
oh
saleh
[Musique]
il
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
où
[Applaudissements]
il y a exactement un an le 28 juillet
2002 le pape jean paul ii présidait la
messe de clôture de la journée mondiale
de la jeunesse au canada à toronto
[Applaudissements]
nous vous proposons en terminant notre
célébration d'aujourd'hui avec le pape
françois de reprendre le chantait d'il
ya 20 ans lumière du monde
lui que de nos yeux
[Musique]
celui que
nous avons pu toucher
celui que nos oreilles
entendue
c'est lui que dans nos coeurs nous avons
rencontrés
voilà celui que nous alençon
et qui resplendit sur la terre où nous
vivons
[Musique]
c
alors voilà qui met un terme à cette
célébration qui était attente attendu le
peuple françois qui vient de présider la
messe à la basilique sainte anne de
beaupré bon il ya beaucoup à dire on
aura beaucoup d'invités au cours des
prochains des prochaines minutes mais
d'abord revenir avec nos invités ici à
l'echa sociologue des religions et
djibouti professeur à la faculté
théologique de sciences religieuses de
l'université laval
d'abord sur aussi on a commencé à tirer
tout à l'heure puis le jeu qu'on
revienne sur le mehdi né n'y a pas eu
une demande de pardon non ya pas eu de
t'excuser encore mais vous dise le pam
parle aussi en parabole hinault passer
des messages dans son homélie oui il dit
finalement avec cet évangile sur la
route du poil à la marche de l'église et
la marche des autochtones
l'église qui peut rester dans sa
culpabilité ou fuir ses responsabilités
comme les disciples d'emmaüs qui s'en
vont du lieu du drame et l'église qui
peut être simplement
démoralisés
constatant ce qui s'est passé il se
demandait simplement mais comment ça se
fait que c'est arrivé
comment cela at il été possible une
telle affaire qui n'est pas dans le sens
de l'évangile et les peuples autochtones
peuvent dire rester dans l'amertume et
restez simplement novices sont un échec
nos vies sont brisées y a pas d'avenir
pour porter ça tout le temps
et
ce qu'il a essayé de faire c'est de
relire notre propre expérience et de
dire ya une possibilité
il ya quelque chose à saisir
alors on passe de je demande pardon
excellent est possible de regarder
l'avenir
et comme on a fait deux communes et
ensemble d'être pour les uns et les
autres frères et soeurs est il possible
de sortir de nos échecs respectifs et
mutuelles échec de ceux dont les
espérances dont les vies ont été brisées
échec également de ceux qui malgré des
bonnes intentions peut-être ont été
complices d'un système qui voulaient
assimiler les autres et nier leur
existence
est-ce que
sk les bouchard
on est la société a tellement changé
est-ce qu'on est en mesure d'absorber ce
message là est ce que la société
actuellement lee peuple autochtone les
peuples des premières nations sont à
mesure de d'aller là où j'ai trop sinon
nous dit que le pape nous invite à aller
j'espère sauf que j'ai des doutes parce
qu'on est dans une société de l'immédiat
on est dans une société où
lorsqu'on arrive avec le message comme
celui-là a je pense que bien des gens là
qui sont un peu désarçonnés face à sport
parce que on s'attendait à des choses
concrètes
alors on est dans cette société de
l'immédiat est aussi on est dans une
société où
de plus en plus on ya des distances
entre les communautés et je pense mais
hier ce qu'on a vécu par exemple avec la
communauté musulmane ici à québec de
voir quelqu'un drame comme l'attentât a
pas changé la perception de l'ensemble
de la population alors ça c'est de la
situation donc on ne peut qu'espérer que
des messages comme cela nous amène tout
à coup arrive à lui et nos choix à
prendre le temps parce que c'est ça on
s'est donné le temps aujourd'hui de
recevoir un message qui était pas à la
hauteur des attentes de plusieurs mais
ce message l'oeil les porter à quelque
chose il faut prendre le temps de
l'intégrer même si on n'est pas
catholique 1 il ya quelque chose
d'humain derrière lui une expérience
humaine car tout à l'heure je vous
parlais que les religions jouissent
souvent ce rôle là une des
caractéristiques du phénomène religieux
c'est que ces institutions là sont
porteuses d'une longue tradition d'une
longue réflexion et d'une humanité que
très souvent on met de côté pour autre
chose depuis métier d'éphémère les gens
qui étaient sur place on disait qu on
peut être vécu ont peut-être ressenti
leur et on allons le voir tout de suite
notre première invitée qui étaient parmi
les
les invités sur place jusqu'à un quart
de l'assemblée des premières nations du
québec et du labrador sud car bonjour
quoi ils se savent en
cours et vous qu'avez vous ressenti
qu'avez vous
interprétez du message du pape
aujourd'hui
l'opt et on avait un peu je faisais
beaucoup de parallèles qui a été fait
avec ce que ce que nous enseigne la
bible et finalement
les défis qui se présentent à nous comme
société société au pluriel bien entendu
et pour moi l'os a été peut-être cette
partie là qui était propre non seulement
au site mais peut-être propre aussi à ce
que représente 52 bon prix un lieu de
pèlerinage annuel donc je pense que le
pape son entourage le vatican ont voulu
peut-être saisir cette opportunité pour
peut-être y allaient de leur propre
enseignement par rapport par rapport à
la situation qui est vécu on n'a pas vu
des excuses réitérées aujourd'hui et je
pense que la question qui se pose et se
pose beaucoup aux survivantes et
survivants
ccl et eux qui ont fait le voyage
jusqu'ici et ce que je voyais ou
constater comme comme sentiment c'est
que je pense que ça ajoute la présence
du pape à cinq ans de beaucoup
aujourd'hui ajoute un peu à
à cette douleur ça dit ajoutant la
douleur mais ajoute un peu à cette
guérison qui est recherchée parce que
les douleurs persistent religions sont
encore dit le traumatisme est encore
très présent mais je pense que la
présence du cabot contre sans doute
contribué à ce que recherche sur chaque
individu parce qu' il appartient
uniquement à l iae de vraiment assurer
la suite
quand avant que vous arriviez on avait
une discussion avec jets de boutiques et
à mes côtés puis qui disait que puis on
se disait tous que le pape parle une
certaine forme de parabole et un moment
donné dans son homélie il a averti
peut-être les diocèses défie-t-il battu
le juge cette interprétation j'en fais
que j'en ai même pas encore parlé avec
gilles routhier mais je veux avoir votre
interprétation à vous il parle un moment
donné difficile fuite est ce que vous
pensez qu'il en voyait là un message à
ces assises
c'est j'ai eu cette même compréhension
lorrain de vraiment se préparer à
affronter les défis qu sera présente à
nous en même temps il a parlé aussi
d'ennemis à travers ses paroles et est
ce que j'ai le lien que j'efface normal
aussi l'hymne des ennemis qui pourraient
peut-être ralentir le processus de
guérison de réconciliation donc je pense
que c'est un message qui s'adresse
finalement à tous celles et ceux qui qui
ont une responsabilité
dans cette longue route de la guérison
et de la réconciliation
je serai picarde l'assemblée des
premières nations du québec et du
labrador merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le
tas au bras merci beaucoup de m'avoir au
suroît avec
avec gilles routhier maintenant alain
crevier qui se joint à nous je veux vous
faire réagir sur ce que je sais car
viennent nous dire et lui aussi le perçu
comme ça c'est ce message là peut-être
que le pape a envoyé à son ex oui il
c'est intéressant d'avoir ce parce que
il la lui également une expérience et de
l'intérieur comment il ressent cette
célébration et c'est intéressant d'avoir
7 et ils disent ça contribue et il nous
lance et je pense que c'est la direction
dans laquelle ils voulaient nous lancer
vers l'avant et vers l'engagement à
faire autant sans marcher ensemble quand
et candy qui vendent à la parole
aujourd'hui android n'est jamais là oui
il sait pas simplement ne pas fuir ces
on peut d'une part
fuir la douleur mais elle disparaîtra
pas il va falloir ou l'intégrer vivre
avec ça sera une blessure qui on va
continuer à boiter parce que on est et
on a eu une balle dans la jambe mais
c'est pas simplement ça nous empêche pas
de vivre désormais on va vivre avec ça
on le doit et pour l'église catholique
elle doit affronter
également ses démons et le mal qu'elle a
pu faire et de ville y est oui et elle
aussi aller vers un chemin avec les
autres orval on va les voir comment les
gens l'ont perçu ce message là parce que
terry nous messieurs y avait des
centaines de personnes qui étaient là
pour suivre cette mèche en direct à l'
exxon qu'est ce que les gens ont
ressenti du message du pape aujourd'hui
les choses s'apaisent même s'ils étaient
à une demi-heure de voiture non loin de
la basilique tout le monde a vécu ce
moment là de manière très intense
lorsque c'était le moment de
s'agenouiller l'ont fait ils sont priés
il ya eu la communion aux six ans ici on
a distribué des hosties on a prévu on
avait tout prévu pour une foule
d'environ 1000 personnes et 6 qui avait
aussi sur les plaines d'abraham c'est ce
que l'organisation m'a confirmé
suivez-moi bruno on va aller aux
réactions parce que je vous ai montré
des jeunes en tout au long de la matinée
et ça se poursuive gabriella
c'est venu en compagnie de plusieurs
autres jeunes s'étaient environ 300 qui
ont fait le voyage un peu partout canada
10 mois la réaction
finalement de tous vous passez à cette
mafia comment vous avez perçu
on est vraiment de peter avec les
premières nations qui s'est vraiment
réel honneur pour nous devons le pas
pour compliquer viennent au canada pour
nous aussi c'est vraiment important
d'être ici pour montrer qu on est les
jeunes notre poids est encore vivant
on est 300 jeunes partout du canada donc
ça c'est vraiment important grand jour à
grand chose de l'histoire
beaucoup merci voyez bruno encore des
jeunes finalement sur le thème y en a
plusieurs de ces genres de groupes là
qui ont tenu à se déplacer qui viennent
de très loin parce que dans le groupe à
gabriella et des gens de bon couvert des
jeunes taureaux tôt c'était essentiel
pour eux de se réunir ici sur les
ténèbres n'ont pas réussi à se rendre du
côté de sainte anne de beaupré mais
comme je le mentionnais ça a été des
moments assez fort qu'on a vécu ici sur
les peines au cours des dernières heures
se joint à nous donc alain crevier je
vois tout votre carnet note je serai pas
de lire ce qui
est ce que vous avez la venue de cette
célébration entre le loup mais lis je me
disais je pense exactement le contraire
de ce que j'ai dit non mais quand
l'usager
justement c'est beaucoup des paraboles
ou des images qu'il faut savoir naviguer
ladd a pu aussi se laisser porter par la
tap ya lieu de poésie la devancer ses
portes et et moi ce que j'avais compris
c'est que quand le pack parler de
l'échec de la déception des moments
obscures je ne pouvais imaginer que les
premières nations et que tous ceux qui
avaient vécu ce drame là et qu'ils ont
et qui sont encore là dedans et lights
est pas un échec définitif il ya ya au
bout de tout ça malgré tout il faut pas
fuir notamment a dû fuir les lignes
c'est ce que j'avais compris à pied je
me disais bon alors finalement il dit la
porte de sortie c'est votre foi et comme
j'avais pris mes notes je reçois un
message de mon collègue charles le
bourgeois
qui me dit faut le voir il propose
exactement l'autre les deux mc gcc ce
cas particulier avec les fameux l'école
les deux leaders c'est à dire les deux
sont pris avec leur passé c'est vrai
aussi mais pour l'église que pour les
nations autochtones est elle aussi c'est
mortifère ce qui est arrivé puis est ce
qu'elle peut en sortir ou si on est pris
simplement avec le remords la
culpabilité puis notre passé qui nous
écrase où c'est peu dire oui on va
refaire quelque chose on est meilleur et
puis ensemble savez j estime déranger
avec ma vision de royautés casque je me
disais au bout de ça si on dit à ceux
qui qui se fera qu'en d'ailleurs de ne
se touche traumatisme si on leur dit
mais la porte de sortie c'est la fois
moi j'ai trouvé qu'on allait vite en
besogne pour arriver à la réconciliation
on m'a dit vous souffrez lemay faut se
réconcilier ou encore je vous fais part
dont je vous demande pardon vous devez
me l'accordé je trouvais qu'on allait
vite en besogne et je trouvais que ça
n'avait aucun sens dans le sens dans le
sang signifie qu'elle fait pertinents
quelque chose que je peux proposer à
quelqu'un qui est encore rendu là il
nous l'avons nous avons été témoins de
tous et de toutes ces choses allaient
mieux votre état potter
le pape on va arrêter seul le pays il
dira pas moi coupable et tout le reste
mais c'est votre interprétation laisse
entendre une
responsabilité à suez
vont pendant que les gens
et on est là pour ça parce que vous
voyez
pia les gens n'osaient plus tard on a
perdu cette habileté que nous avions
jadis peut-être dans les années 60-70 ce
que tout le monde allait à la messe
chaque dimanche on a perdu cette
habileté de d'interpréter la parole
bible et interprété également lomé dit
et là je vous amène sur une autre
interprétation puis explication qu'on
fera avec vous j'ai l'outil
nizza il était vite en besogne oui le
maire le pape les allées sur les
formations professionnelles souvent je
parle plus sexy
actualité religieuse donc
tout ils étaient vite en besogne
l'interprétation vous nous proposez
c'est que cette semaine du pape c'est la
marche à suivre
chose qu'il restera faire peut-être sur
dix ans pour la réconciliation
je suis sûre modèle et aimer les ids
mais peu importe imerys un email et hier
processus de réconciliation ça demande
du temps et elodie il faut s'y engager
mais effectivement c'est en raccourci en
une semaine
le programme qu'on doit pas courrier est
passé de la reconnaissance de sa faut
l'affronter chimpanzé de ressentir la
blessure
de demander pardon et ça ne se commande
pas un parent dans les airs et ses longs
mois je parlais à quelqu'un est bien
vrai pardon et dis moi ça m'a pris sept
ans à part donner quelque chose
des fois j'ai des fois on n'y arrive
jamais exactement on peut dire j'ai une
disponibilité je cherche je voudrais
bien
mais c'est ça et ensuite
offrir le pardon parce que on se met
vulnérables face à un autre c'est à dire
moi non plus je peux pas vivre si tu me
donnes pas la vie
puis ensuite arriver à la déconsignation
mais moi je trouve ça très intéressant
la marche des jeunes mères ça me faisait
penser à la marche des jeunes
autochtones également y avait il y avait
servi
d'autres créations qui nous arrive de
sainte anne de beaupré mendy gaulle
mathy qui est un grand chef du
gouvernement de la nation crie qui est
avec nous alors elle fait partie des
gens qui était fort probablement
l'intérieur de la basilique avec qui le
pape entretenait cette conversation
d'abord je vais prendre mon âme de même
6 1 une première réaction qu'est ce que
vous avez parce qu'on dit que la demande
de pardon et les personnels qu'est ce
que vous avez ressenti aujourd'hui
spécifiquement dans cette cérémonie
merci à bruno c'était une très longue
journée en premier je trouve qu'il y
avait plusieurs nations ont chacun leurs
réactions aussi au niveau d'un outil
visuel c'est vraiment à un message
personnel on voit des personnes ici qui
sont tellement
encourager
mais aussi en voit l'autre l'autre
spectrum de responsables des personnes
qui sont pas ici qui sont pas réparés
forcément aussi
quand on disait que puis c'est drôle
monsieur picard me disait à peu près la
même réaction c'est que vous vous étiez
là n'oublions pas qu'il y en a des
centaines des milliers qui ne sont pas
là aujourd'hui qui ne participe pas et
qui ne sont pas intéressés à ce qui se
passe cette semaine
oui c'est chacun ses sacs c'est à chaque
personne qui décède pour les autres sons
ou dans l'art
dans leur processus de guérison
cet événement a été quelque chose
historique on voit qu'il n'y avait pas
plus beaucoup de monde qui ont un revenu
et aussi on voit que c'était plusieurs
affaires du planning le timing aussi
c'est durant une période qui a beaucoup
d'un festival pour les autochtones moi
aussi je croyais à plusieurs personnes à
la maison qui ont décidé de regarder
cette émission les massages du peuple
entourés de leur famille
merci beaucoup grande chef dalmatie
d'avoir pris le temps avec nous et bon
retour et puis bon
bonne guérison j'ai le goût de saisir
comme ça parce qu'on vient de l'établir
que c'est un long chemin merci d'avoir
été avec nous reste peut-être deux
minutes puis je me tourne vers vous j'ai
l'outil ce soir les va être qu'est ce
que c'est l'oeil vaut s'adresser
principalement des représentants de
l'église catholique oui alors c'est
peut-être important plus qu'on ne le
pense
quand il est allé aux jmj au brésil il a
rencontré tous les évêques d'amérique
latine je le redis écouter celle au
convent voilà le chemin et moi j'attends
quelque chose ils vont rencontrer des
intervenants pastoraux les évêques des
prêtres pas touche des diacres et des
laïcs intervenants pastoraux et
probablement qu'il offre quelque chose à
nous dire en dix ans comme église
je parle
prenez le relais et c'est leur content
on a pas à
dire maintenant c'est terminé on arrête
on ne fait plus rien je vous l ai bien
oui c'est ça alors non à leurs yeux les
vêpres il ya un autre événement
important y participer at il ou pas il
ya le repas fraternel des autochtones et
des évêques ce soir aussi ce soir
également les vagues alors la journée
n'est pas terminée
malheureusement vous serez pas là pour
nous aider à comprendre et à interpréter
le message du pape ce soit parce que
vous êtes justement occupé à c'est à ces
deux événements dont vous venez nous
parler mais on gardera en mémoire
l'enseignement que vous vous avez
partagé au cours des deux dernières
heures des trois dernières heures je
vous dis merci beaucoup de vent faible
dissipation le mieux votre âge à l'est
nous reste et minutes on se l'est dit
c'est parlement ce choix que l'on veut
avoir le le film ou d'histoire est à
fait moi aussi --qui a pas eu un moment
où on peut dire à ce sujet figure biella
ya toujours un peu tassé de surprise à
il peut être à cause de la nature même
de ce personnage qui est capable à bord
d'un avion de dire des choses comme
exposé alors lancés à tir et on sait que
c'est dur avec le clergé il a démonté
d'amasser et puis demain mais il s'avère
qu'à l'ouest dont on ne parle jamais et
il ya un gros oiseau un airbus 330 le
kit ressenti va atterrir l'achat de
process pouvait l'ignorer oui maintenant
et alors je sais pas ce qui va se passer
mais qui reste dans deux événements et
je ne dissipe pas les diffuser et on
sera là pour vivre ce soir encore
émission spéciale on va s'y retrouver
pour suivre avec vous les 20 près et
d'avoir probablement des réactions
puisqu'elle y est vous y en a partout
vous dites on n'en parle pas beaucoup
mais je dis tout de suite que j'aime
bien là à cela et vous serez de cette
couverture non pas et kalou 8 mai à
distance pour suivre cet événement de
québec nous vous avons présenté cette
grande messe en provenance de la
basilique sainte anne de beaupré
j'oublie tout à l'heure on va se
retrouver en fin de journée pour les
vêpres et au nom de toute l'équipe merci
de votre attention passer une agréable
journée toute l'actualité suis au réseau
de l'information
chacun étant je m'en viens culpa
la première chose que je voudrais ce que
ces paroles c ce que
j'aime dans le cas de tous les
survivants et ceux qui rentrent pas cela
pour ouvrir le capot guérir les
blessures
il a été honnête en inde et se sont
aussi là les interrogations brûlant qui
résonne dans le coeur de cette église en
belle rainage au canada sur cet
éprouvant chemin de guérison et de
réconciliation
2011 nous aussi face au scandale du mal
et au corps du christ blessés dans la
chair de nos frères autochtones et mon
mari nous sommes plongés dans l'amertume
et nous ressentons le poids de l'échec
et comme notre bière et fo cela par la
crise nos seniors
[Musique]
les one date vous tidiane wane les innu
tahin hp beats in les nôtres
na cornic
l'écrit mais gouache les attikameks me
bottai
[Musique]
jeudi 28 juillet au téléjournal ce midi
[Applaudissements]
nos pères et de fils et du saint-esprit